[ __ ]
[Music]
all right all right testing testing
round
what is going on put the crust up in the
chair oh man wow already wow salute
hollow hello hello to dawn
hey welcome to the lord bronze welcome
to the run put the crest up right quick
man put the quest
up for our brother salute for joining
around much appreciate it put the horns
in there
someone yeah someone joined last night
sometime
oh yeah shout out but shout out i'll
speak to saul but salute yo hustle and
motivate thank you brother for the audio
cues as always sixth slayer i see you
what's going on
is that the legendary paris lily the the
fortune teller
the fortune teller of xbox uh salute on
the prediction
sir we saw that and uh good i was
appreciating the comment he's like
usually never get a chance to watch live
but today is a different
day no doubt we have the legendary acg
and the building should be a fun
show governor grimm i see you what else
we got
the pet pen today penitent one
interesting
mine for hire i see what's going on yeah
man it's gonna be a fun one
real non-stop talent salute and um
so i don't know what's going on with you
aiding for salute salute to you
[Music]
but um yeah man it's gonna be a fun one
attic talk to the people real quick just
make sure your levels are good
testing testing chat make sure y'all
hear the wolf
make sure y'all hear the young wolf in
here no doubt
casket repair what's up so yeah man
we're gonna get
rolling soon we will get the legendary
acg in here
king will be coming in hot and soft
should be on top aaron summers what's up
brother good to see you
good to see you bro but anyway we will
back oh yes
appreciate you hollow much appreciate it
you know what i'm saying we definitely
want to shout you out on that
so anyway yeah they said you sound good
and uh yeah we're gonna get the show be
started in a few
we will get back to you and uh talk to
you a bit all right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look you gotta mess up and turn me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical
and yeah i'll be eating these rappers
but that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they wanna compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but i am addicted to flipping the
sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got
[Music]
you i always been a nerd never been a
loser making voltron with a gang of
cougars and i'm going places better tell
her uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep
on freddy krueger
let's do that again
[Music]
imma just chill and watch them any
snacks in the attic i wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young wolf
but then they would mistake me for attic
if i can imagine it's cool to give you
some advice and invite your girl to your
squadron cause if you don't give her
that option you gonna be single player
like siren you're gonna get tossed in
the bushes by king david royalty ain't
not a pretender
detrimental to an elemental what's the
avatar to a knee bender i gotta be me
though
i know it's my destiny worked a cognito
who cares if you fly if you're still a
mosquito you swear you ain't something
but really
you like to collect stuff and that's
cool but i got bad news
even if you really watched that joke
king david still be the king of the
statues
since the juvenile i've been cursed with
a curse to be musical and if you hate it
we'll meet in the crucible other than
nothing it's cool and it's beautiful we
let you know that your dreams are
pursuable whatever you want to do then
it's doable if you got work on a sunday
it's suitable cause you can listen to
this in your cubicle on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on a lord's day
[Music]
right all right and hear ye
hear ye and we are live
welcome to the iron lords podcast and
also live
on lordsofgaming.net episode number 200
200 gentlemen congratulations
oh a little man it don't feel like we've
been doing it
though it's crazy brother like what's
funny is technically
uh you know especially acg like we
actually have like an extra 15 episodes
he's just doing destiny yeah but then
when we went to everything i deleted
them
yeah we threw our devil tape for the
bushes
so no one will never know
it's another glorious sunday and we are
back at the round table on the lord's
day
i'm very excited about our special guest
and we've got phil
spencer confirming bethesda game
exclusivity
but kicks now but that's the case to gay
fast
it's sony's potential response to
disgust so we gonna get right into it
i want to introduce a lord who in my
opinion represents the gold standard
pertaining to honest and balanced game
reviews
not only do his talents as a reviewer
exude a precise level of technical
detail
but also match his extremely passionate
and humorous opinions
in the gaming podcast landscape
introducing the creator and host of the
acg
youtube twitch channels the best gaming
podcast
and the co-host of the defining duke
podcast
the lord of cheese puffs and carrot
crates
the most iconic beady in the game
live from an undisclosed location and
making his debut
into the realm of the lord
my man lord acg aka
angry centaur gaming how you doing sir
i'm doing good thank you very much
awesome intro
i'm glad you knew about the cheese puffs
oh i love it that's important
that would be crazy i'm glad people now
know that
absolutely you are lord in your robot
what you doing absolutely pleasure to
have you pay respect at the round table
how you been man what you've been
playing like what's been going on with
you yeah i've been doing loop hero of
all things
which is an indie game and not my style
but
uh a company contacted me and they're
like you want to check this out i was
like nope
i'm really open i'm like nah not my
thing and uh
she she was like well if you can check
it out if you like it you like it if you
don't you don't and
i sat on it for a couple days and if
anybody hasn't seen this loop hero it's
even hard to describe
it's like a rogue-like roguelite
game uh i i downloaded it and i haven't
played it yet but i
there's a lot of hype around it dude
that's exactly you know how sometimes
i don't know about you guys but like
i'll be reviewing a game and i'll be
like i wonder what other people think
so with loop hero i looked at it it
looks like a snes game
you know it reminds me of like the old
times where people pretend those
graphics were good
okay right and i'm playing it
and then 18 hours went away and
it was and i'm a person that i'll stay
up for 24 hours playing again without
any hesitation like if i like a game i
don't have any
perceived time limits and i i emailed
the person i'm like
this is one of the greatest experiences
of my life but i can't explain it oh wow
like it's the first time in the history
that i've ran the channel where i'm
having difficulty explaining what the
game is but it is
phenomenal as a time saver
i am looking at it they sent me the same
thing like i'm have to try it like i
have the code i just haven't put it in
i'm about to try it yeah you got to
check it out man yo
kings i see you got that royal mug
salute salute i i see you rather
than thank you for on live i'm sorry you
want to get the quick super chat before
we get into intros
uh we got smitty smith with the 20 hours
we chat salute to the lords on this
fantastic 200th episode
and yeah so lord i dizzy 81.
we got something new for y'all for our
brother you know what i'm saying put it
up right there for the days right there
yeah
put it up for the dis man salute to him
brother he's always going to be with us
salute the graphic golf uh coming up
with that very on short notice
and we're always going to miss our
brother man thank you for that it means
a lot and the family wants to send their
love to the realm
shout out to mama dizz lady dizz you
know what i'm saying
young lord parker they they watch the
show they watch our tribute they really
they really appreciate what we did today
we realized how loved he was in the
gaming community so salute to y'all if i
could make it happen dizzy fantastic
what else we got today yeah so lord
dizzy the visionary because he knew this
was special
i hope he shields up thank you sir yes
sir we got smitty smith once again five
dollars super chat welcome everyone to
sunday service the book of acts get in
front get in front of the congregation
it's ready
[Laughter]
and uh we have the flame with the five
dollars from the chat hear ye hear you
wait a minute is that no here you hear
you lord king on the ground
of lord's day can you tell the people of
our realm
what all the noise was this was about
this week seems
pretty crazy this is something wait did
i miss something this week
yeah it was there was no news this week
i don't know
it was just i told you so we're gonna
let you get your your bars off we know
anyway here we go hustle and mortar wait
two dollars if we check congrats on 200
iop
keep going don't let much appreciate it
brother but again
lord acg so it's just been that one
anything else get a chance of stuck in
gameplay-wise
yeah unfortunately nda's so i can't talk
about some of this stuff um
but uh i in this february it's dead
month for
youtube because there's just not a lot
of stuff so it's been i finally hired
somebody to help me because there's just
at some point this has been four years
and it's been just me and
at some point i needed some help with a
couple things so i've hired somebody to
help me and just doing stuff behind the
scenes actually
february is a good month to sort of you
know pull back
and see like what your plans are and
especially with covid and all this stuff
like things have dramatically changed
even what i wanted to offer in the disc
in the patron has changed because like
we've actually had barbecues where
patrons come to my house
oh now admittedly people probably think
that's dangerous
i don't care excuse my language but it's
like i don't care i mean
dude i've had cancer twice do you think
people coming to my house is going to
scare me
that's that's life you know whatever
they they can find me pretty easily
and so i invited a bunch of people but
now you can't do that right
yeah yeah you can't do that 14 days i'm
not going to pay for a hotel for them to
quarantine
are you there are people that actually
watch and see how many people go in your
house do you understand this
yeah you know what's crazy are you
having a party you're having a party
out of all out of all patreon you are
probably the only one that's doing that
yeah that's that's
that's so unique to you bro
it's awesome to meet people i've met
patrons had them stay here like
to me that's dude that's what i don't
know how to describe it
i lived in a i lived far away from
everybody else and so there wasn't a lot
of communication in
like you know i would go to school and
then go home and you're seven miles away
from everybody
so you're like what am i going to do
play with the trees they don't talk back
which is probably good
because i'd argue with them but like
when i've gotten older it's like yeah
how
joining people together in gaming is all
that matters
all that matters we we're going we are
we're trying to uh
establish some things like you know i
was talking earlier uh we're gonna get
together and
for our patreons uh we're going to do
like a movie night and yeah we do
b-movie night on saturdays
do it yeah do it don't rent out a movie
and we can you know
do that you know spacesuit seating
watch a really good movie you know
awesome they open back up you know
you definitely uh want to give back to
the community you already know very cool
and your song i'm going to get the last
couple before i start because there's a
couple more just flew in real quick
i have a 108 dragons tv five dollar
super chat
damn cogs guest intros are legendaries
and entertainment
appreciation good afternoon lords uh one
away dragons tv in the building was good
chat hit that like and share it happy
birthday
happy birthday
this episode is going to be wild they
got their mixtape
ready six hour podcast
sunday sunday sunday
like those games where like when you put
a certain variable in it it just extends
it it's like
put acg extra two hours playing yeah
it's the n plus game but just a really
bad one that's probably not going to be
that entertaining but stick around
we'll try to make it into them we got
something we got one more one more we
got michael aka best size finest five
dollars for attack well hello
lords hmm smells like this playstation
elves are being handed out yo king have
fun today
on god oh god of them earlier
wow yeah
yeah yeah he'll see he'll see today
today's a day to come on today is a
perfect day to come on anyway oh real
quick cause i see him in the chat it
makes me smile
salute to bitcoin gaming put the crest
on yeah
your fight salute to mama big cloud
yourself
with your fight and the whole situation
with colvin we're pulling for you the
whole realm is behind you
take as much time as you need and
definitely get back to health brother we
need you
and we miss you so salute to you good to
see you in there man it means a lot
and last week i've already got a pumper
and then we'll get people yeah
with the five dollar super chat king
how's that game pass buffet looking now
hello these knees on the menu there we
go because they they go never gonna stop
anyway let's start all right you already
know we got the four horsemen of gaming
those original lords of the realm at the
round table
with some time-sensitive in uh intros
because we got a little acg here
my co-host with the co-most my brother
from another mother the difficult game
conqueror lord of his own world and the
how
of the young wolf my man lord addict how
we doing sir
i'm doing pretty good now last week i
gave king and solved my intro now i i
i demand half of your intros there you
go but
anyway it doesn't matter
i'm back into uh for some reason i just
started playing final fantasy 8 again
out of nowhere i don't know where that
came from
like it was normally one of those things
i was just going to play a couple
minutes of
and then like eight hours go by i'm like
well damn
and then i was looking at the
achievements i didn't know a mega weapon
was different than a different weapon so
i'm like well now i gotta go kill him
and you said it was an achievement tied
to that right that you'd even yeah well
see i always thought the one that
that a g ever named eden was in i
thought he was that
one no there's another one oh wow
it's been a final fantasy 8 that you
ditched us for a raid where we needed
your help
and you ditched us because you i don't
have my save point because i
am not no no no no no no no
no hold up hold up no no no he can't
he can't make allegations like that i
joined that raid and done it
first off two hours later it wasn't two
hours later
[Laughter]
but anything else you've been playing
sir i ain't talking anymore
all right all right he's he's upset i'm
just joking
i'm going home taking this one vintage
picture
and of course we have our most technical
gaming lord the solo gamer who lives for
the single-player selfish experience
and also the sastradamus the lord of
clarity
and lord patron of the iron bank my man
lord sovereign how we doing sir
i'm doing well i'm very very happy to be
here today
oh once again i'm faking it because i
have literally like three hours of sleep
oh welcome okay oh because yeah i sti i
stayed up i saw the time change and i
was like oh
i i just lost an entire hour yeah i'll
play for another half hour or so and
next thing i know it was 6 30 in the
morning yeah yeah ouch
yeah that was it and i never get that so
yeah like like
i mentioned earlier so i i downloaded
loop heroes i really wanted to
see what this is about because
everybody's talking about it and i did
not get a chance
i threw it on for a moment and then
people don't leave me alone
so i can't i can't i can't so like acg
said it's very difficult to describe
from what i've heard
yeah but basically you don't control
your player character you control
everything around the character to sort
of allow him to progress or her to
progress
um and that's as much as i that's as
much as i understand
of it um and maybe that's even off um
but beyond that like i just started uh
i threw on my xbox really late last
night i said what am i going to do
and i i went to need for speed hot
pursuit the remaster
criterion is still still so that is so
fire
i put it on okay menu is in the same
mind frame this
raw yeah right because i did it randomly
for no reason
i said because i looked and gained past
i said oh hopper
let me let me try this let me let me
dabble let me down man i'm gonna jump in
there
amazing i love criteria and that game is
is is no that was their last one right
no was it the last one no because they
know it because they did um
they did burn out paradise and stuff
after that okay we want to get a super
chat i'm talking
i'm talking about nephes that need for
speed was their last one
uh hot pursuit was criterions right i'm
not sure
that maybe an acg question okay i don't
know that one i'm not even sure of all i
know is
hot pursuit and uh and paradise are both
awesome
some of my favorite racing games of all
time and then i played halo 4 because i
felt like playing halo 4 and
that yo that game still holds up it's
the gorgeous uh
the ai is a little weird but apart from
that it's gorgeous you know what i'll
solve you want to get those super chat
before we bring in the king
yes we have it's tony bryant
with the five dollar super chat iop plus
acg my favorite podcast podcast and
favorite
reviewer absolutely plus phil waiting
until iop's 200 episode to announce
exclusivity keep it up guys
let's put the crest in the chat for the
newest member of the realm
lexication
thank you thank you thank you then we
have lord brat
with the two dollar super chat salute
lords thank you my brother i already
know
yeah we should have a chocolate oh my
god
oh i'm sure he will i'm sure i'm sure he
will
then we have electrocution and once
again with the 50 dollar super chat
absolutely sir great raid last night
glory to the lords victory eternal oh
yes yes we'll talk about that yeah
salute let's get the guys
had a good raid last night they kept me
in for four hours but we're not gonna
get in there shout out to fosse
gaming my man fozzie is funny
i teach him about that anarchy dps face
but we go we ain't gonna go get it
we got it done we got it done all right
what else we got two more super attacks
we got one way dragon tv once again five
dollar super chat
the my feelings hurt menu barbecue sauce
knees
in garlic sauce and knees
drinks the gas face hold that l game
pass on the rocks oh my goodness
what a menu that is then we have cedric
h
with the 50 dollar super chat thank you
so much salute i did that for you
salute oh yeah i got you i got you i got
you with the who do that
i got you all right uh we let's let's
get probably
let's get five dollars acg love your
reviews king
i have chocolate that's for your knees
well
um you don't have no knees right now i'm
taking your elbows
if you don't know what chunk letters are
those are flip-flops
songs when i grew up those were thongs
that's how
that is how crap has changed like every
single decade
you're like what word is it now
[Laughter]
all right we got one more and then we're
going to put these on the shelf a little
bit
lauren anderson five dollars chad i
appreciate how y'all represent the
african american community gaming keep
up the amazing
representing the african-american
community thank you thank you we
appreciate
we appreciate your service thank you bro
you've been going strong bro
let's just admit let's just submit two
members
oh
yeah we're good all right we're going to
put it on for a little bit because and
of course we have the incredible hulk of
this aka
the access gamer who the prophet of
xbox king of the statues who demands
nothing less than that premium
experience
it is the leader of the fraud alert
movement
beloved lord king how we doing sir
i want everybody to ride for me to put
your band nets up
this is gonna be a glorious sunday 200th
episode
but we got to start it off on a very
sour note i woke up to some horrible
news yesterday very horrible news
marvelous marvin hagler
probably one of the greatest midi weight
champions to ever live
the toughest out in boxing if you saw
his name on your docket you probably got
sick that day and did not want to show
up for work
because you know he brought his lunch
pail and his knuckles and you was not
going to escape that fight
um sugar ray leonard i got to give him a
shout out for even daring to fight the
man
yes beast is a
a true beast a warrior of a man and a
man that stood on
pure principle alone hackler was uh 62
and three
with two uh no decisions and 52
knockouts the man's uh fighting career
spanned from 1973 to 1987
and when i tell you he got in the ring
and he did his thing
that's when boxers were i don't know man
lifting bricks and stuff like that
it made a lead made a leg completely a
different type of fighter
and that is probably the only fighter
that i would pick in history to be
uh floyd though both of them
in their prime he is the only fighter
in the history of boxing that i will
pick to beat floyd he's basically
with that being said i've had a
fantastic feedback
i would imagine too
especially this non-news that you
predicted oh well let me tell you
something okay so
on friday right i had one of my uh uh
co-hosts
on uh dcx there to uh call me out
uh what was going on this boy did
oh god what's going on he said that uh
we could play street fighter for a
statue
so i know y'all actually was missing and
y'all like whole kingdom
wait a second hold on not at all
let's go so so i went
and i found through i made sure that he
was online so it's a whole big diatribe
to it but we're not going to get into
that
make sure that he's online because he
was lying saying that he added me so i
made sure i added him in real time
so we have about his chat with like 30
plus people
and we shout out to facebook because
when you put a video call everybody can
yeah everybody can see the world
everybody can see this work for you so i
didn't have street fighter 30th
anniversary because you know i'm a game
pass dude i was like oh it's not getting
past it
yes we we know how yeah
he's literally acg you literally said it
like if it's not in game fast
it does not exist sometimes because i
pay my 29.95 to download because he had
to get all of this smoke
you understand so when i proceeded to
download it he was talking and i put the
phone call through
and everybody got a chance to see it i
appreciate it just
proceeded to wash him up like a brand
new baby
which street fighter we played all four
of them oh
regular street fighter street fighter
turbo and his street fighter alpha and
there's street fighter third strike
he got working all of it so we finished
it off in third strike
and i did not switch my character i
stayed on ken ken is the man
you got them boots of the mouth i told
you watch your mouth when you're talking
about me
you get them boots anyway okay what i've
been playing on game pass oh oh let's
get it what should we go oh
man go though so my son came downstairs
he came running downstairs i thought
something happened
mm-hmm he said daddy daddy
this 20 new games in game pass
[Laughter]
i said well what game you're gonna start
off first i said you're gonna play uh e
within he said no daddy i'm not gonna
touch that game
i said okay so what you gonna play he
said daddy i have no idea
i gotta really sit down and put real
thought into this i said well you know
um try some fallout or whatever i'll be
playing fallout 76 maybe me and you can
link up
yeah i'm gonna start my downloads now he
walked back up the steps
he said daddy can i um have chips inside
my room
i said on this great day you can have
chips oh this is a great day
wow you can have chips inside your room
he looks
special in his eyes and said
thank you father
[Applause]
messianic
yeah exactly i played doom 64.
for the first time since i actually
originally owned it on the super
uh i mean the nintendo 64.
amazing i download fallout 76 i'm going
to get into that i got to bend the knee
to
anchorman because yeah yeah they've
really improved since
i played a lot of games but evil within
i want to go into that because i was
um i'm really super excited and we'll
talk about that later
but when i turned the game back on
it said sinking your data i forgot i was
at that boss you know the chainsaw dude
i forgot i was at that boss okay so i i
did it i beat him
and i said this game looks so
magnificent uh
the the the atmosphere the the the bee
film feel to it it's so great um
but game pass it's so many games there i
can't go into all of them but i did some
raids this week
and i'm gonna tell you frauds out there
oh what happened
if you want to raid and you want to
finish your rage really quickly because
i heard y'all was running my man
oh we're going for four hours raids that
don't work with me
if if you're messing up i'm gonna sit
you down i'm gonna call in
uh somebody off the bench that's gonna
play your role and then we're gonna get
you through it and you're gonna see how
it's gonna be done
but we did some rage yesterday and we
got them in quick
and easy so to hear you doing your raids
that was horrible yesterday brother i do
apologize yeah yeah salute to lexico she
didn't even salute to him but uh that's
been it sir
yes sir yes no doubt and of course we
have the gaming ninja himself
the shinobi lord cognito spreading that
realism around the iop
not telling what you want to hear but
what you need to hear yeah like you said
been a
raiding also salute to my brother lord
ibontis we had cobb one art man one of
the great
artists in the destiny community super
talent also like a
70 80s baby so he got a chance to talk a
little old school hip hop some music
and you know great episodes so check out
the last word it's upper island podcast
we had a great time with that
i want to salute uh the newest members
of the ilp
uh destiny clan king did you hear we
have gaming forte
and randall for 19 new destiny clan
members
so i got a chance to run with them with
this shot of throne you know so we're
trying to get him raid ready so he could
do a tough first
send them my way i'll put them in my
book bag and i'm
running through this stuff because
there's a particular way i like the game
oh no
i have no doubt so we've been doing that
and again shout out to the crew last
night back for dead all stitch
my man liz execution up in here polygons
and pixels
again thank you for keeping me up to
damn near four in the morning last night
for doing a very adventurous
long raid but salute to y'all but that's
all i've got super just solving that we
got to do something special for 200
before we bring acg in right
yes sir yes sir let's go let's go um we
have pixel big g two dollars we'll chat
good morning laura's let there be
exclusive slander
then we have 108 dragons tv with the two
dollar super chat king gave his son the
xbox pep talk
that's classic
then we have uh smitty smith with the
ten dollar super chat it's time for the
playstation captains to put some respect
on phil ilp dominus maximus aurelius's
name
and i will be ben
oh my goodness yeah we're good i think
we're good
wait i have a question real quick for
you guys yes sir i'm
i'm just picking this up so are you
stating that people thought
for some strange reason that those games
were not going to be exclusive oh
they still think that some still do
there were there were
many theories this is it there's no
theories
you know what's funny when uh that whole
thing happened with monday
where they kind of like a little cryptic
and and i remember i
i remember like i started losing faith a
little bit just a little bit i saved it
i got on twitter and i saw
i saw you holding the line acg i was
like you know what acg
right we got this we own that
i mean there's there's a certain stage
of grief people are in there you need to
move on
like you can cry all you want but sony's
done it nintendo's done it
and this is microsoft's done it like you
need to just
leave the discussion if you're gonna cry
about that like that's for sure
happening
you're just gonna have to like that's
the reason why i was so
belligerent about it is because i did
have sources telling me
a long time ago that there were very
specific things happening those all
turned out to be true and i'm going to
tell you right now if you're expecting a
bunch of the games
like if you're expecting him to be on
multiple platforms including
other very particular competitor
consoles who by the way were trying to
buy exclusivity
for star field do you think microsoft's
going to be like you know what we're
going to play
by a particular set of rules nobody
else's we're just going to be nice 7.8
billion hey
that's a loan we're going to buy this
company everybody can play we're just
going to borrow the
seven points we're just going to borrow
it dude there's multiple things going on
in business
and if you if anybody thinks tv
manufacturers aren't doing the xbox game
pass app you're completely
you're missing everything about what's
going on sorry
the number is going to be a preview of
first topic and you will find
should be a game pass commercial yes it
should
then we have general mac 5 shout out to
iop
and shout out to acg thank you lord
sovereign for the heads up on the
youtube runs of dishonored yeah ah look
all of the dishonored one dishonored to
uh pray
those games that didn't get the love
that i felt they deserved when they
originally came out in a nine game pass
i love the fact that people are
gravitating to these games yeah yeah
play these games they're amazing games
amazing games i really enjoyed
dishonored like it
i felt like dishonored didn't get to
love it well i mean this dishonored one
did but i felt like dishonored too
didn't like
try try it out man you even if you don't
like your viewing gamepad you just
delete that dude right afterwards like
but i think you like it once we got
solved uh we got one more
we have smitty smith five dollar super
chat microsoft to sony
you get nothing you hear me nothing now
fix your facebook
[ __ ] book of acts early on on the
lord's day jesus we have scripture very
early very scriptural
you know what i've noticed um i'm very
iffy
on outriders and uh uh where are they
going to land but
i've noticed that uh yeah there's some
talk i know we'll get some
things happening that might give them
time time yeah we're going too long we
got to get in this good day
get it all right come i'll solve
something for the people
oh of course okay so uh we're gonna do
our quick patreon giveaways
that we do every patreon youtube that we
do every month so thank you everybody
for
rocking with us for 200 shows so we're
going to get into this first our regular
patreon giveaways and we got something
special for the round no doubt
all right so our 10 gift card giveaway
goes to fake excitement
andrew golson okay as you go
salute salute make sure yourself up yes
sir yes sir
okay our 20 gift card giveaway goes
to get the excitement in
it goes to no one needed it
we're keeping it we got heated heavy
505. oh he's
heavy salute to him yeah good dude could
do it like that no doubt
fantastic so hit me up later on and
we'll get you that stuff absolutely and
of course
now the winner of our teespring giveaway
is let's go who's getting the eye who
could get the crest to drip let's go
who's getting it who's getting there
lord snaldo oh in-house
in-house he's gonna probably petey's
gonna want to re-roll it but
i got him yeah petey's definitely gonna
read the brother you might wanna
yeah i know petey peter's gonna be like
i know give that back to the to the room
yeah
as we assume your generosity yes yes we
got
smitty smith with the win
like he really wanted it
[Applause]
himself salute smitty
is as much as smitty really really like
he he's in here every week very
deserving
yeah he's one of our biggest fans he
said yeah
boy he got the [ __ ] x in the chat
he's at every unboxing that i have
actually yeah he always even when we
were at the shows we were at like packs
at 83
he's always yeah he's always loved
salute to smitty smith man what else no
doubt no doubt so now
as a special gift to the realm and our
supporters on patreon and both youtube
uh this gift is courtesy of
our good friend lord lord paul i i like
to call them suave love
oh
doubt uh long-time friend the lord
cognito and of course about myself and
lord king
uh big supporter of the run from the
very beginning
both me and him our hearts are uh aching
right now but we got hope
hold on hey you might get the show
shout out to lord paul uh two 100
american express gift cards for
uh one for our patreon uh subscriber and
one for a youtube subscriber so we're
gonna get into that right now the loyal
rim
hey yes sir so uh the winner of
our youtube from our youtube subscriber
pool
is oh you better be here you better be
here
who is this off james shepherd oh okay
sounds like a mass effect character okay
shout out to james shepherd's brothers
is his brother like a clerk at some
point
yeah shout out to james and calvin
he's like i wanted the real shepherd not
the generic oh
we appreciate it um i will contact you
to get this to you
yes so now the winner from our patreon
subscribers
and now vr facebook gaming oculus quest
2 i'm going to be gaming with you too uh
brother because i got my questions for
you
is coming this wednesday he'd been on me
because he said i am not a gamer until i
play half-life alex
so i gotta try that that's true yeah and
then it was one more game i've got
someone else too there's a lot of games
in there yeah
it's funny that bill won because again
he's been on me and i've been the knee i
have
it's been ordered the quest is this week
so we rock out
i'm yeah that okay so that that is it
once again guys
thank you 200 episodes we would have
never thought
thank you for rocking with us thank you
for supporting us uh we
every single week we do our best to
bring you funny new content um these
guys
great guests yeah amazing guests so so
thank you so much we really really
appreciate this one no doubt anyway
let's just
clean up get out of it sometimes during
the podcast look at that chat
uh i'm gonna be dropping a few codes in
that chat so all right no doubt no doubt
so i clean up your super chats and then
i
got to get acg going uh ex give me one
moment because i
i was a couple things right there and i
see a couple people
i see hawaiian uh c yeah after smitty
spiff i got it if you want um
hawaiian was here i better start
listening to the king and he's raised i
heard about you
all right continue now we have jd gamer
with the five dollar super chat sony
sony sony you get nothing sony now
go home and cry like a good fan boy if
yes who has the games now
god is evil it's not like a final boss
character the way he super does
it kind of really is the final boss to
be honest jesus
then we got the homie pick cloud gaming
with the 20
super shot on the men's brother we're
praying for you and your family
yeah uh get well soon man get well soon
brother
no doubt no doubt thank you for showing
up brother all right so
now that we finally got all the business
the giveaways and all that good stuff
out of the way
and uh lord what they've been playing
and everything but i want to focus on
lord acg
his video game system history his
journey as a content creator
his podcast beginnings and of course
we'll let him create the most honest no
bs
game reviews on his amazing acg
youtube channel so lord acg let's start
from the very beginning what were some
of the first video game systems you had
and what got you into gaming
i taught well i had i had the
old ass like calico
i had the one and i don't remember the
exact name but where you could play like
tennis and there was also a gun that was
connected a western gun
and they forgot that you could shoot the
ball
when people were playing tennis so my
parents would be playing tennis and i
would shoot the ball and just piss my
brother off and tell him to chase me
around the house
those are like the earliest memories but
atari 2600 like that was the that was
the big thing to me was
and my dad um i have amazing parents
like amazing but my
dad uh he was just a super hard worker
that was how he showed love was just
hard hard hard worker and uh he owned
his own fish plant for years so we
didn't see him a lot he would come for
christmas
it was he would come home at 7 p.m
christmas eve we had open presents he'd
go back to work
and then the next day 5am he would go to
work so he's working like you know 19
hours a day so we'd rarely see him and i
remember him coming home
and he was excited and i was like why is
he excited my dad
was just not that type of guy he just
doesn't get excited
anything like it doesn't matter he'd be
on a roller coaster just going
sorry i took him to the grudge by the
way the scary movie the grudge
my mom's freaking out i'm like damn my
dad is
it's like he was watching people saw
logs he was just
no bloody that's why my dad but he comes
home that night with a 2600 and he's
like
giddy and dancing around the house and
we're all okay obviously he got into the
crank
somehow he got some drugs i have no clue
what's happening
he shows up he opens this thing on his
own he doesn't even let us the kids open
it up
and it was an atari 2600 dragon fire and
asteroids and
star wars and and terrible games like et
which i did own
those were the first experiences that i
had and it grew from there and it was
like every good experience that i've had
has involved either
well role playing is another one but or
martial arts but it's like the three
main course for me or martial arts um
role playing in video games and almost
every good memory every good friend i've
met
has been involving video games from the
2600
and then moving up from there to like
the genesis and
it was weird because people always ask
me why i cover sound and music and it's
like
because i still remember the original
ghouls and ghosts who had a soundtrack
that played in a very particular part
that caused me to be like what is that
like what and then like revenge of
shinobi i was sort of a sega
i got to stop you right now you first
you said you said some key things for me
as a genesis lover so you said music and
then you said uh revenge you should know
because i
love you that's my namesake i am shinobi
so my question to you is um
with like something like a revenge of
shinobi and maybe a streets of rage
i see someone was it a yuzo cyril love
possibly maybe some uh
so that's the thing about me is i was
not following the
the creators at the time like that came
later like austin wintoury
i follow the older stuff i loved street
street uh
streets of rage is awesome but the old
streets rage are even better and i love
the music from those
creators but i was always impressed by
their ability to take technically
because that's what i study is is the
tech behind it uh technically
very inept consoles create awesome sound
and i remember the first time i ever
played a game where i was like this i
want this to be my future
and i remember to this day coming home
and playing joe montana sports talk
football
oh i loved that it was digital
yeah he talked and and by the way it
almost needed subtitles because
but
montana drops back for the pass and i
remember coming to work the next day and
i got in so much trouble
because i would not shut up i was like
go i was leaving my class to go talk to
friends go
have you played this yes like he talks
he talks
and of course as a kid you're like it's
really him
it's like a spirit it's his spirit
it was man i was so excited and that's
that's honestly that kind of stuff that
tech
and and just the different ways in which
you can do
[Music]
like older games and the way they
created stuff is great we have some rose
tinted glasses obviously
but we go back to me i when i go back
and look at those
i may not love the graphics or whatever
but the tech behind it where somebody
figures
the ability to do something and do
something with
hardware that you're just not expecting
what they had like but yeah when they
did up the
the meg size on the cartridges yeah we
knew to be excited
right yep yep you did and it's funny
because there's a game star
control 2 i believe that on the genesis
used 16
uh 16 megabytes but what was weird some
sega genesis could not read it
so i admittedly traded out my friend's
sega genesis
sorry absolutely and i stole it
i took mine over and i'm like hey randy
your dad's calling you
he left and i switched out sega because
he didn't play it anyway
and that way because his ran it and mine
wouldn't but that's the thing those
those are the tech moments and that's
the excitement like i've been excited
for games since that joe montana moment
and i j i love it like it's interactive
art to me i get the art
discussion and i i i understand where
people are coming from but to me
every friend that i know is probably
from games
even if they're a work friend i probably
talk to them about games and that's how
i
you know got to know him probably and
it's just it's
it's just awesome man like you know i
know that people are like man he can be
brutal at times and i can but
my opinion is that games is probably one
of the greatest
entertainment avenues that we as humans
have because it's music
it's interactive it's graphics it's
story which
i love books man i read like a fiend but
they're not the same people i did but
later later
when mode seven started oh i was like he
joined when i joined him
did you have did you ever get a chance
to play act razer oh of course
yeah oh yeah yeah i love accuracy the
first time i got that game right
and i put it in that was the first time
i thought an orchestra was inside a
cartridge
that's the thing right and you know we
know now you listen to it you're like
it's like
wow exactly but as a kid yeah as a kid
you're just like this is the great
it's almost like we see a b movie and
we're when we were kids we're like those
look pretty real
and then you see them now and you're
like how did we ever think
but that's the excitement to me and
that's like to me that's the
it there's a passion for games that is
just like i can eat it up for
hours and tech is i'm huge into tech but
it's also just like
austin wintry who's an amazing composer
i've had him on my channel multiple
times i would consider him a friend
absolutely um the guys from outer worlds
probably one of the best
main menu i love tracks have you ever
heard in my life
yes i have to agree dude it's like mass
effect
yes no lie i did not start mass effect
for
almost two hours because i was just
listening to the starting yes
that rare the synthetic that flash
gordon and i was like
this is this is the best thing that's
ever existed
i'm a kid man even now if i find
something good
i'll be on my discord being like dude
you just don't understand it's the
greatest thing ever and i know that
people are like
man like i am too extremes but
i just think that if you lose the
passion man where are you like why are
you even in it
why are you in it yeah if that's going
to go away so but i would say they're
all just really
gaming as a whole every even bad games
they're all good memories in a weird way
it's something that it that will key to
you about that game
like i like splatter house
fake jason voorhees running around dude
turbo graphic 16.
oh my god i love you the hue card
remember the hat
yes yeah
and i saw it in egm and it was like it's
going to be on genesis
but turbo graphics got it first yeah
yeah
and i i could not wait to play that game
and i played that game
so much it's horrible the game is
horrible
yeah but it didn't matter
it's got pixel sprawl technically it's a
disaster
and i remember going home playing that
and telling my friend it's you exactly
like the arcade which you're full of
[ __ ]
that's right you got you
i'm just like dude it's not but it is as
a kid
yes that passion it goes away and
i i wish it didn't because we get into
something
weird where it's like very technical to
me i celebrate the tech and a lot of
people ding on it they'll be like oh
it's
59 frames versus yeah steve you're just
like okay seriously at some point
what are we doing my brother you know
you're on fire right now because again
all those memories those different
errors and then what i like what you
said that a lot of people
forget is there are iconic
title screen game music and it's funny
you said that because i could actually
think of a few more like outer worlds is
definitely one of them
i just let it sit there and the ship's
going and you hear it
and i was talking earlier about star
wars i mean star trek
yes and that beginning sound yes yeah
yeah
yes it's like that you know some some
uh developers take the time to craft the
title screen
yes exactly that's everyone i think it's
a good point obviously
you're about to say something i said you
know when you first start the outer
worlds and
i i remember there was two key
components like when you hear the
the title screen and then when you start
it and he picks up
your pod you was like this is gonna be
it like
[Laughter]
i mean yeah and they've been doing this
forever i mean you think about double
dragon
you know what i think that comes from uh
for the older crowd
going to the arcade room and
watching the demos start up yes yeah you
know because we would sit there with our
quarters
waiting first let's see the beginning
yes watch the whole intro until it
started
over again then we put our chord in and
let's get started
and just watching them watching other
people play prior to you being able to
play
there's a uh there's an amount of data
that's transferred that is not
transferred currently so
even though i love game pass you can
just click a button right it's like your
random generation
seed of today you just click a button
whatever game may come up
you can play it that's great but there
are also those times where
when you sit and look at a game and you
see that start
that title screen or you watch somebody
play and you're like oh there's a move i
didn't know of which
by the way that is i think that's one of
the best things about like twitch even
though i don't always watch twitch i
love
watching somebody go are you kidding me
for example neo too
i beat neo2 twice and fighting cowboy
one of my friends
will stream and i'll be like what didn't
even know about a different game
like how did you that's the same weapon
i used oh yeah but this is low stance
you use medium and high which is
completely separate
and there's something about watching
that
that
uh voyeurism that comes up there's data
there
that's not just the dirty type of
voyeurism it's
actually coming away from it informed
and
uh music hats off to those guys because
they didn't have a lot of ram
and they still got it yeah they were mad
they were magicians man they're just
never magicians you know it's something
that i think a lot of developers don't
get credit for
is you know since we're talking about
the title screen like games that when
you get to a certain part of the game
the title screen changes
oh yeah i remember i just did um um i
just did dragon a uh dragon quest
11. and you get about halfway through
the game the title screen change
yeah that's crazy like last of us when
you beat the game the title
um the craziest thing the voyeurism what
you're talking about
i remember peeking through these two
dudes arms right
because they were um playing mortal
kombat yeah
and i saw him do the kano kill
took his heart out and i said oh my god
exactly and i stayed in the arcade
trying to figure out how these dudes
right
before the internet yeah and why why
don't i know it
tell me tell me how what what did you do
and one guy he he had a ponytail that's
why i can't stand this
oh yeah we all hear that story jesus you
know ponytail
and the longer that freaking thing is
the more you're like dude that's
it's like a health bar for their
i said how did you do that he looked at
me like
[Laughter]
dude this is great we gotta move on we
would talk about
these stories all about honorable
mention halo gregorian chance
at the title and yeah of course uh
fallout i felt another iconic
um title screen joint but one of the
yes absolutely so we got that we got
like i said the sega air right now i
just want to
travel further with you well as far as
gaming oh you're little bit in the
32-bit era
and like oh yeah any 3do any anything
going on there
and technically neogeo which i heard
king talk about one time
yes so first of all you always knew your
friend was rich when they had a neo geo
because you were like dude that's that's
that's a car by the way
that's like a cheap used car the neo geo
cost that much
and i had a friend who had a neo geo and
then i jumped into 32 i had everything
out of saturn i had all of the stuff in
fact i
showed up the day the saturn showed up
six months early because sega panicked
and we're like here let's release this
three months early and it had your
street fighter
your daytona and one other one uh though
street fighter
game of all time or virtual fighter i i
apologize virgin fighter is my favorite
game of all time
just a huge like it's the crap for me
but
yeah i had them all and i pretty much
had them all i think the only one i
didn't have it was the wii u the one the
fake wii
the fake thank you thank you thank you
actually
couldn't figure out if it was they
wouldn't dude i had people who were like
is that even new or is it like a tablet
for the wii and i'm all
man they suck thank you
because i i die on this hello podcast
that it was not popping that we have
some wii u apologists here
well i mean it can be popular it's just
they failed their pr yes
that's where i come from one of my
backgrounds is pr and
they failed completely just like sega
failed
completely sega should not have put
another wrist processor in the saturn
they should have stuck in the 2d
and sony they found out sony was doing
it and they were like let's stick
another one in there and i remember
talking to a dev years later
that's actually how i first got in the
business talking to a dev for sega and
he was like dude
it was a disaster wow you can't just add
a processor back then when no one knew
what multi-processor was
they were like we're just gonna we're
gonna throw another one in on this
motherboard
and everybody was just in such a way
that's the thing wait a second
was it mark cerny in charge
second processor because it was like no
matter what you did
on that console you had to go through
the two processor you couldn't buy
this correct one so everything had to go
through that two-step bottleneck
and it was just like oh my god it was
like brain
i looked at that and i was like why why
did you do this
because you know mark thought it was a
great idea
anyway but anyway yeah so those are
really
like those are like i i've owned pretty
much every system
and i think the 32 is probably my
favorite but then the dreamcast came out
just about to ask you that and um
unfortunately
we can talk about you know we don't have
to but the piracy thing we don't know
we know ea you know they refuse games so
that sort of hurt it as well and then
there's a piracy thing but
the dreamcast there was something about
it where i still remember
where friends would come over who didn't
like games
and virtual tennis or something and they
were it was just
graphically okay let me tell you a story
this is let's
it's about 3 a.m i've stayed up for two
solid days playing dreamcast
games with a friend on my weekend this
is the way i was i'm always like i'll
die tomorrow like i don't care about if
i'm tired
so i'm playing these games i fall asleep
with and this is not a lie
kadee's one of my friends in the discord
real friend saw this
i go to sleep with nfl man
2k on yes and i wake up i was far enough
away from the tv didn't have my contacts
and thought it was a real game
totally was like what you know you're
blurry-eyed and i wake
up and i'm like you know look in my
boxers looking at this thing going
who why are they playing you know two
teams that wouldn't play at this time
you know
like play off kind of i'm like this is
the wrong time
like it was that when your brain is all
foggy and i had to get up close and then
i was like do i tell anybody and cadiz
lived with me
and i was like you know it's five a.m in
the morning on a work day and i'm still
waking him up going like dude
we got to tell somebody about this like
what an idiot
oh dreamcast was just so ahead of his
time
i'm glad 2k what was it visual concepts
at that time
everything everything except baseball i
know i know
yeah right that was true ea saw that
they probably had the same thing that
happened to them and said we gotta shut
them
down real quick right you know shout out
hustler motivate to the gator lord
roughness got that premium hoodie salute
i wanted to shout out you guys
i promise to shout you guys out on that
and um i definitely want to get on so we
got the um
like i said the 32 bit error then all
the way up into i just wanted to ask as
far as um
playstation and the xbox the
introduction of ps1
and xbox like how did that go for you
i the xbox the hard drive because i'm a
tech guy the hard drive in the xbox
excited and i still remember
one or two of the racing games by the
way i believe one was need for speed
would allow you to play your own music
amp did as well which is
project gotham and i project gotham
which by the way
anyway yeah project gotham kudos are you
are you a metropolis street racer fan
dreamcast
mind-blowing and so i got rob zombie it
was like dragula or something like that
playing while i'm playing need for speed
and i remember thinking like this is the
future
because it was the future there was some
i i
could not believe that i could just grab
you know
music get it playing on a hard drive and
play those things and unfortunately some
of that stuff stopped you know as like
all about licensed until you know people
bring it up and i was like yeah
why did they stop that licensing yeah
i mean okay i guess you know i i think
twitch killed it because you're playing
like your music to a game that you don't
because i would play wu-tang with
everything
you know so oh right that
xbox hard drive was lit remember we just
put our own music to the that was
revolutionary for me you know
it's just that thought you know that
that was a good uh period of time so
if you can go back and do it yeah you
know by all means tremendous man oh man
he's gaming history but i love this type
of talk oh last quick question i gotta
ask how four's forget
what about were you any handhelds or you
kind of stayed away from handhelds in
general
i had a game gear which which lasted for
about one minute with the batteries
it was it was a master system in
handheld like it was the worst design
ever but i had that i had a turbo
graphics 16 which is the coolest
handheld i've ever had
yeah the express sorry yeah and uh that
thing was so ahead of it so go ahead
you used to sit next to the wall with
the plug-in with plug-in
yeah i just
and i still was i was blown away by it i
i remember bringing it into school and
showing friends and they were like oh my
god
and it was it was basically the the
console in
absolutely it was amazing yeah oh dude
yeah it was massive
it was like it was like swaddling a
small baby
but it didn't matter because i was
playing these games just being like dude
this is the coolest thing ever and uh
yeah
all handheld tv tuna of course dude
i got i am a nerd for tech so
i had everything any cartridge
expansions that you can get like you can
play this
you know old style cartridge on this i
will buy like all that kind of stuff i
definitely get i'm just sort of a nerd
for that did did you have the nomad
yeah well i had it okay nomad did you
have the sonic and knuckles
and then they and they did do the thing
yeah where you add like all three games
and it worked like
it worked it was like i have a 32x dude
which like i'm one of the six people out
of 32x and i actually enjoyed
yeah i was like one of the six ripped
off by sega completely
got a 32x and i loved it i loved it so
you had you had the uh the big mac
burger and the fries the stack
uh with the sega cd the genesis
and to me like all that kind of stuff
because i love
tech i was blown away regardless if you
like it or not i was blown away that
somebody did it
yes somebody was like you can add tech
on top of tech and to me that is
um it's it's awesome and i celebrate
those kind of things anyway like we do
podcasts where we just talk about tech
and i'm like
ima for example i'm a big fan no one
else is
i get it but sega saturn
king loves you don't worry about it okay
xyz right it had your six face buttons
and
or you could get six and you could get
six on the genesis as well in their
extra
mat their genesis controller i can't
remember what it was called it was a
special controller
i'm a big i i still want six buttons on
the front
the face like i'm a big fighting fan i
would love an extra button on the face
and so when i talk to developers about
it i'm like why is that not there and
then they talk about the white and the
black button on the xbox the original
little baby itsy bitsy ugly
camera button yeah and then i'm like why
is
it and i talked to an xbox x
manufacturer of this so i'm like why
is it that people have forgotten that
americans have big hands because the
duke came out
and that was my favorite that's why it's
called the dividing
because i want to pat that thing like a
track pad
the biggest controller i don't like the
switch because it hurts my hands i love
the switch
but it's actually physically painful
because that big hands and i like
that big burly controller
that feels like it's a small rc car
yes that's what i want right i want to
be like you know singing the song from
lion king while i hold this thing up
yeah and then maybe throw it to the
monkeys but
i want that kind of stuff and no one
does it and we actually had a discussion
and i found out it was it was pure price
the parts were bigger oh and they were
like yeah
and i was all men of all the things you
know with
especially now we can talk about this
but the customization nation that we're
sort of in now where
you can customize everything you got the
elite i don't know why somebody
i've never seen anybody say here is a
big mac controller like that's what i
want
somebody's like hey fatty here's a
controller for you
i would i would buy it by the way if
they were like hey we're going to call
it the fatty
xl i buy two
please put them on my nipples and do a
naked picture
i'd be like paint me like your french
girl
they won't do that stuff right and like
i love that kind of stuff i
like all and that's what i thought was
so awesome as we got more and more into
all these different systems the
customization 32x
on top of things i love that stuff man
there's something very cool about it
completely agree with you brother i
think like i said just
king agrees off all of us like yeah we
were
such a fan of tech and the advancement
of gaming so all those things you
mentioned like i said the add-ons and
the controller stuff the
vmu the dreamcast i remember the power
based converter
for the genesis that allowed you to play
sega mass systems so that was like the
first almost back compat
in a way like physical right back of
that you know kind of thing yeah
just those type of errors it was a it
was an excitement
for the new stuff it was excitement to
see where gaming was going you know that
kind of thing
so yeah salute to you on that man
tremendous gaming history man
what's up brother we got seven hundred
yes please hit the like share
he subscribe said that he would put two
big giants
yeah we might have to clip that one dude
hey yeah send it out i i mean it i would
if companies listening right now
what are you guys what do you when he
companies just
send an email acg said he'd do it clip
it
yeah so i want to transition right here
because uh as far as you said like your
personal journey as far as
content creation now you know what i'm
saying now correct me if i'm wrong
i understand like you kind of started
like almost like with video game mods
and then
q a testing correct yeah okay so um like
how did that start and then kind of like
what
inspired you to kind of transition the
spearhead to your channel and
from a review standpoint like how did
that whole thing go
yeah i was i was working at the time um
i'd set call centers up around i worked
at hp and tech and then i'd set up call
centers executive protection some other
stuff
i'm definitely out i want to do
everything so i'm like i've logged
done retail like i'm always trying to do
something new
and um i was into gaming i was doing
these mod organizer things for
uh for for skyrim and
or not even skyrim at that time i
believe that yeah that was skyrim and
messing around with mods
and messing around with things like
operation flashpoint is one of my
favorite shooters of all time because
you can go in and make a level in
seconds and just say let's play and
and i got laid off and i had worked um
i had scrambled for years because i
didn't get a college degree i scrambled
for years and i was
like worked really hard and i knew at
some point you know
it's probably going to happen i'd never
been laid off before but i was always
prepped
and my wife had just got through college
i paid for that you know where where
i was working and uh and she was she was
going to school so i got laid off
and i started like one of my friends was
like dude do you realize that
like you have a forum where people ask
you about games and you're not a youtube
it was prior to being a youtuber people
were like there was a forum where people
were like hey what do you think about
this and i realized i was breaking it
down
like some news before i was like i could
probably do a youtube channel and see
how it goes
and did a youtube video that did so well
you
youtube was like can't be real and they
turned off monetization
it's absolutely yeah one of my first
videos they were like this absolutely
can't be real you couldn't have done
this well as a brand this was back in
the like the
wild west days and they were like it has
to be fake
so we're we're removing it and i sat
there and i had a discussion with my
wife i was like i have some retirement
what do i do do i do i go back into it
um
you teaching martial arts or personal
you know training that kind of stuff
and uh we just said let's stick it
through and let's see like
let's see what happens so spent some of
my retirement getting a little tech
and then uh and they decided and i will
say i got into reviewing
i think the main thing for reviewing i'm
not dissing on anybody and i even told
you
this on a twitter like i'm not like
there's some things i hate in video game
reviewing and some companies i hate
um the only one i will mention is that
when i was looking at reviews i was
seeing like ign cover a 60-hour game in
three minutes
right and i my brain was like i can't
i just don't understand why anybody is
okay with that right right
it's not it doesn't make sense and so i
just decided
like that's what i'm gonna do because
i'm gonna break it down as much as human
as possible i've made music since i was
super young since the first like
electric daws came out
and so i was like i'm gonna do music and
i knew some voice actors i was like
and so that's sort of how it began and
with the anti-pc or
[ __ ] excuse me bullcrap stuff when i
say like
not two minutes long yeah that's a shot
at companies that do short
reviews um that is a shot like that is
why i say it but the other one with no
bs is because
i studied my wife's a psychologist and
i've studied psych all my life and
especially as a martial arts teacher you
have
tons of different students who have
different psyches yes
and there is no support none by the way
so if a pr person lies to you because
they are lying
they're not mistaken they're lying if a
pr person lies to you in states
a person can get something for free and
it will not affect
their end judgment that's a problem
and that was going on a lot we had the
uh jim sterling
yeah thing we had a couple other things
where people were being shipped off to
go to places
so i was like i'm gonna buy every game
right and i was like if i get a game
what do i do and so what i did is i made
a guideline a series of guidelines prior
to
making the channel i was like what
happens if i get a game so for example i
have every vr headset because i do vr
headset reviews i'm
the biggest i just love vr and i have to
buy everyone
i do music headset reviews i have to buy
everyone
but i just feel like dude people are
being lied to i don't know any other way
to describe it like you're being lied to
if you believe that and i've had pr
people who are my friends who are like
no blah blah blah i'm like dude this is
what i did i studied it
there is absolutely no scientific
backing whatsoever anywhere ever
that has ever stated that that does not
change your end result
no it does change absolutely true
because that's why i preface everything
when i when i say game pass when i'm
going really crazy
and stuff like that i got to tell people
that i am compromised
i'm absolutely compromised i have been
bought and sold
so at no point in time do you take it
really for the gospel
and somebody that is coming from the
outside that didn't purchase this like
when i do a statue review
i purchase all my statues there you go
that's nobody sent one to me right
because you're gonna get an honest
review and there's a reason why
that's why i do a kos behind it there's
a reason why but
the only way that you can know that
somebody is actually being honest in
their reviews is
they didn't get it for free they
actually did this they purchased this
with their own money and they're going
through this with their time to give you
this stuff
all that other stuff where they say oh
we're um
we're unbiased that's bs yeah uh
it's not only bs but scientific there's
studies for this white
white paper studies that you can get you
can go online to multiple different
research facilities that are in studies
for this
and the first thing they'll prove is the
opposite is also true indicating that
if you get something for free you could
treat it as
i'm gonna throw it away right away if it
sucks right you will also do a thing
where it's free
i'll give it more of an of of a time
frame where i'll play it more because
it's free right those are all
that's human psychology man that's you
you've got there's some things like sunk
cost fallacy all that kind of stuff and
this is what i trained on this is what i
did
and so it's like when i came into
youtube and i saw it and people were
just lying to themselves and my personal
opinion is why lie about it
like instead embrace it embrace that's
why i'm big into language so like when
i'm talking about a game and i'm like
dude you cannot say
gatekeeping for like bethesda being
bought by xbox because
sorry pr wise gatekeeping was created
and gatekeeping's actual genesis as a
word is something that cannot be
translated to what is a current
what is currently occurred gatekeeping
originally was sexism it was racism
and it was physical access this is
bitching sorry this is complaining
that somebody basically like if ferrari
found a cool type of
chair massager and they bought it and
said you only
can get it in ferrari that is not
gatekeeping
and that is exactly what's happened here
and you will have to deal with it and
you'll have to suck it up and for
whatever reason gaming in particular
we have an issue yes with that yes and
that bothers me it bothers me that we're
not truthful
and that's why i started a channel
because because that's the way i am i'm
just like nat sucks
and i'm not saying it sucks as in
everybody will think it sucks i'm just
saying i'm going to give you all the
context i can to tell you why i think it
does
and then you can walk away and say i
agree or this you are on fire right now
brother i got to hit you with the you
are on to something you are dropping
crazy knowledge on in that part as far
as human psychology as far as reviews
and also um
again taking it outside of ram again not
to for me to
to bash on any other sites or forums but
you know what you're saying
in reference to more than just you know
a couple of minutes for these huge
massive games dude you know what i'm
saying
yeah it's just not fair obviously to the
creator the dev themselves
and into the experience because there's
just so much more to the experience so
that's that
and get in i've always thought because
like the way the industry works now is
like especially like people
coming up it's a lot harder to grow
without that industry up without because
yeah you know when you're when you put
out reviews a week or two late
after if you don't have a huge following
to like base it up and get you in the
algorithm it's almost
impossible so i've always thought like
you know the industry can do more to
like if you're an established reviewer
or content creator in general like
look let you pay for your copy and get
it when we're done
they're spoiled yeah i want to do it
that's a good point and again
back to lord acg with his style and
everything and then
like what i like is again what you said
you take it beyond
the this sucks or this is awesome you
don't say that kind of thing and then
you know what i like particularly i
watch your outer worlds review
and one thing that you did that you
helped me understood why i liked the
game
because it was like really cool you were
like yo this thing is just spitting out
these great color the palette the
expression i was like yeah
that's why i like it because i was like
it's something about this just vibrant
neon
yeah and it's just a different take and
it's just your
technical approach to it right it's just
so cool
what i wanted to ask you though like is
the origin of the style because it's
again
it you got you got the dope yes you got
this cool it's funny ejection of humor
like
like how did that hole develop like just
kind of culminating in your style of
course that iconic
rant you don't say buy rent never touch
kind of thing yeah like how did it come
together you developed your own style
um that is me so people on the discord
will tell you like watch out if it's 3am
and carrick's on a roll about like
there's actual memes it's like oh my god
he is on like
we we will not have to deal with two
hours of him or anything about something
like that that is the way i am um i've
always been super high energy and
i where we grew up i was on the pacific
west coast okay so
you have um you know i would say
predominantly you
have you know english speaking people
but we lived in a town with a great
number of japanese and thai
and tai happens to be one of the fastest
information languages in the world i
believe it's almost twice as fast as
someone
as in words per minute the amount of
data delivered
so my friends by the way one of my
largest contingents of fans are thai
speakers because they're like dude
you're slow to us
but americans will be like dude what did
he say like what is happening
right now i gotta listen to this three
times so that's what i grew up around
and i grew up around
friends who just happened to be there's
dennis leary has a style that was very
fast
and uh george carlin yes george carlin
when i grew up george carlin had a
tendency to talk fast now i remember my
family was like dude
you talked twice as fast like my mom
would be like you have to slow down
and i'm all i'm already on tomorrow i
don't even know when she wants me to
stop
and uh that's just the way i was man and
i think that uh
it just all boiled up and also i've had
weird crap happen in my life
so like when i got into gaming it
doesn't matter
like i told totalbiscuit this because
totalbiscuit and i had a weird
relationship until we met
and he was one of the greatest people
he is proof he was proof i apologize
that that you can see somebody and meet
your heroes or meet whatever and it can
turn out to be
far far better yes than you expected
that's rare we had some
we had some back and forth and that dude
reached out and helped me when he had no
cause i was sort of getting on him
on some stuff and um when we started
talking and started looking at the way
everybody handles games and all this
kind of stuff it just came about where
it was like
he was like dude you're really no bs on
this like you just say this
i say it this way blah blah blah and we
just found out that
for me that worked when i try to slow
down it's a
nightmare i when i'm bored it's a
nightmare i
like my family would be like dude the
worst person in the world to be around
she's bored it's a disaster like i'll be
all
like a friend will be all hey man you
want to come over and play board games
i'm like yeah if you've got music
playing
a movie playing in an audiobook oh yeah
you are
like dude what yeah i am i like
he's the same way he's got to have a
bunch of things going on otherwise yeah
listen and then we'll spend eight hours
watching bob ross
yeah yeah he's my favorite guy in the
world bob ross will be like i used to
shoot people
in vietnam
about him i did not know that he was
this wild drill
dude it's a lot like uh like mr rogers
where they had these
different backgrounds and and that's
what got me into art and color by the
way was bob ross because
bob ross would be like that you know
there's no there's no mistakes i
definitely for martial arts i
sort of don't agree but i can't sleep
without the tv on and it has to be yeah
at a certain decibel if the room is
quiet
i get up like i like it what's going on
something's wrong more like when the
power goes out at night my wife will be
like i can finally sleep and i'm like
whoa
whoa whoa wait a minute there's not 50
decibels of white noise
i have an issue i need yeah i need it i
need it so so i would say that's how i
got
you know the speed of discussion and
stuff like that's pretty slow for me
and i don't re i don't write the reviews
i record them in real time so
for me um it's a lot of memorization
speech memorization and thinking this is
what i would say if one of you guys was
at my house like i would drop a william
shatner joke
like that's the way you guys are like
that yeah when you're right i mean i can
tell
automatically that you guys are so what
i do is i just memorize what i'm
thinking when i play
and then i just am like stop everybody
just character with acg and usually slow
it down by twenty percent
so people can understand classic that's
like
you just think about key parts that you
want to talk about
but then you just give your honest yeah
i think i see because
i think when you do that it flows it
flows and you know the funny thing acg
is like
i can't do that because like my mind is
like it can't keep up with my mouth
right right so i have to like write down
key points and then
i used to script videos and i stopped
doing that because
i would script the video i would be
reading the script that i just wrote for
two hours
and then my mind like oh i didn't say
this and i'll try to like like
try to make it then it doesn't work
real quick before we get to super chat
lord six slayers really
ask he's a big fan of he's like what
discipline do you practice he had to ask
me this
for martial arts yes uh so when i was
five i started
gojo karate and then uh jeet kune do
and then kempo i've got three black
belts and those because again i don't
stop moving
as you can tell even now i just let my
dogs out um
i and uh most of them now i teach boxing
and general martial arts because
classical martial arts have sort of gone
the way of the
dodo you know when i grew up it was like
brandon lee's real
yeah anybody who fought was like
probably not admittedly he did cool
stuff but you're like and bruce lee you
were like
i don't know how that would have worked
so as things have changed um
and then i'm big into fitness because i
do have health issues in the past
cancer and stuff so i'm like i'm always
trying to make sure that i'm doing
something
and so yeah and i would say right now
it's probably
just like a general fighting you know
just everything mixed together
absolutely
let's get a couple super chats and leave
a little bit behind i don't want to be
disrespectful to the realm
okay we had a squirrely dan with the
five dollar super chat congrats on the
200th i couldn't miss it even with life
busy as hell
thank you here's to the next 200
episodes give it up in the chat for the
lords thank you
thank you brother then we have sean
jackson with the ten dollars we chat
king
when xbox is an app on all smart tvs
sony gonna beg to be in game pass like
ea
and you be sometimes people ain't paying
for all them separate subs then phil
gonna say to jim ryan
who did that for you no no hey savage
yo real quick i forgot to shout out um k
asante i saw i saw you salute you know
that source of data
copped it all out you want to make sure
the merchant was saluted continue
no doubt then that's let's welcome to
the realm lord two east coast it's two
east coast
some east coast west coast okay okay
biggie and dawes and jay okay i see you
two east coast in the house uh yeah so
put those crusts in the chat
then we have faisal 007 with the five
pound super chat
sega saturn had the best start screen
games the burning rangers game
yes in the jet stream
say good night fantastic
tempest son five dollar super chat been
a patron for uh for close to five years
of acg
not going to stop anytime soon best in
the biz
yeah our tip uh just the tip even though
it's technically called
the international podcast but we we came
up just a tip yeah i think we hit like
500 i've only recorded 300 because
technical issues in the background
but like you'll record one and be like
oh no it didn't save
yeah but yeah dude they're all patrons
and they've been there since
day one it's always nice
sounds like you guys are the same way
it's always cool when you've got that
patron who's like remember when you open
the discord the first day
they reminded us they were like remember
when there was only five people in here
yeah
you mean it's awesome they'd be like you
were mad that your friends didn't show
up there
up
when there's so much going on that
inside jokes turn into emotes
that's what you know oh vogel's creed he
got that classic t
with the trap he said finally got some
iron pieces got a shirt hoodie hat and a
mask
now i'm all set to wrap the realm that's
right just don't do nothing illegal
while you wear the masks and all that
stuff that's all
that's whatever you do that's you or no
be infamous i
[Applause]
[Laughter]
but i'll bend the knee to the lords and
return on sunday
absolutely thank you brother that means
a lot thank you thank you brother
needed him for sure absolutely
absolutely then we have
another new member to the realm m-10
let's put the crest in the chat for f-10
what's going on uh then we have adam
mask with the two-pound super chat
project got them on 360 is
undefeated for me yes is
amazing i love kudos um then we have the
darsh knight with the five pound super
chat
salute my brothers turned up late have i
missed much sauce
xbox games now
[Laughter]
salute then we got b lou with the two
dollar super chat original zelda the
best title screen music
slash music okay okay okay go respect it
then we got black ronin with the 10
super chat my first time listening to
acg
and bull is spitting big fats yes
i'd know shout out to our new but ben
family of bethesda and the future games
exclusively coming to xbox class game
pass
ecosystem you already know then we have
flame with the two dollars which had acg
just saying your elix review made me
wait for a sale
i got you i got you hello i got you
absolutely
you know what a an amazing thing on that
is too acg
especially like you're you being so big
in the reviews i'm sure a lot of like
dads have
watch your reviews and when they're
making the sequel like yo acg didn't
like that let's let's
tie that back a little bit i can tell a
story about forza if you have a second
oh yes please
i would love to hear this okay so i
dissed on okay so forza's ai in the last
game
the last forza horizon if you put it on
easy because i test all difficulties
because a kid this might be a
that's another thing people have this
weird lineage
history where they pretend everybody
knows every game somebody be like you
didn't play final fantasy 7 it's like
dude the guy's 16.
it sounds like addict to me sounds like
adding to me continue
right so so don't appreciate it yes
you'll be shaming people if they don't
play certain days
you test it on you know all the
different difficulties and on on easy it
would crash on purpose
oh now no one else mentioned that
because honestly i don't know of anybody
who tests all the difficulties
and i was like it matters because you
never know where the bump is
and i put it and i got this email dude i
put that video live and that email came
in like
seven seconds after that video went live
and it was like
can we talk and i'm the dev for the ai
and they were incredibly nice
and they stated here's why you see what
you see here's the resources
that were put into the various different
uh levels of difficulty
and uh they do watch um i hammered on a
submarine game of some kind like avaram
it was a weird name and the very first
post
was the developers stating you're right
about every like yeah
it's it wasn't ready and they were they
were like thank you very much
never change and and by the way improved
it now it's awesome
so you know which we see with sea of
thieves we see a woman scott we see this
happen so i think for the most part
they're fine i did have one time where
somebody accidentally forwarded me
on the reply so i said can i get a game
yeah wb
listen to this i requested a game and
they were they emailed me back and they
were like yeah no worries and then they
accidentally did not remove me from the
forward oh so you were part of
the correspondence let me tell you that
was mean
it was not just
we don't like this guy oh
yeah it was uh physical stuff it was not
they're gone
they don't work anymore but it was it
was crazy it was like
so you've landed gra yeah oh dude
like i was like man if i gave it crap
that would be
terrible what was this responded back oh
you were smiling
oh yeah i was actually like yeah i've
been losing weight i appreciate it
wow yeah dude like who
like like that it's an email like was
there you're not going to steal my first
silence was this silence after you died
there was an apology from multiple
people that was very good
it was very good and i think for the
most part it's very good
um developers have a tendency to be like
i mean as long as you're accurate
there are some people that you can tell
they haven't played a game yes you
by the i mean you can tell and those
devs you'll see them in like steam forms
or whatever and they'll be like
that's when you can tell if you're not
accurate if you hate something and you
explain why
most devs will be like man that sucks
but yeah but if you
are inaccurate that will that will black
that i that's probably where
blacklisting comes from
is the inaccuracy i'm not saying i don't
like something but when they feel you
are
not uh respecting the time right right
it's insanely disingenuous it's come i
mean and that's your job
like of all the things in the world if
you're a reviewer shouldn't you review
something
yes it seems good point
i'm big on you know if if you're going
to criticize something you need to
explain why you don't like it
yeah just add context to it right no
that's that's the core of
addict did his reviews yeah i don't i
don't like that this is trash i'm like
well why is it trash and when you
actually explain why
they realize that they don't know why
it's trash they're just saying because
they read another tweet from another
youtuber that said it's trash like yeah
yeah
true no i hear you man solve you want to
finish up and then we can keep it moving
yeah uh once again let's welcome a new
member to the realm gaming types pat
gaming times patrick welcome to the
realm i'm sorry hello absolutely
no doubt that we have the list 22 with
the
super chat great brother congrats lords
on episode 200 but
time with last night's raid slander yes
yeah yeah it was two
hours no no it was four it was four and
you guys
we all don't let me get started
you know what's funny you you could
thank cognito because i almost went in
there yeah i added oh you was almost
accepted today would have left
no i wouldn't have left but you wouldn't
have liked me you would have unsubbed me
afterwards
it was two hours we can discuss at a
later time but i have receipts
two hours for some people in some
segments
we're going to talk about that tracks
fight that i say but anyway moving on
moving on time
time moving on butterball with the five
dollar super chat please say something
thank you
appreciate it then we have citizen
sleeve with the one pound super chat
once absolutely
thank you so much for joining us then we
have family corey hale with the ten
dollar super chat
congrats on the 200 episode lords i hope
you bend the knee no no
we have christopher hart oh christopher
4 dollar super chat
are we admitting that game pass is a
great rental service
rental yeah yo chris yeah
yeah you know what else is a great
rental service
your console oh my god especially when
the internet goes down you're playing
outright
factual fact he's on to something he's
honestly yeah we got
then we got sarco with the ten dollars
should we chat below made a solid point
with zelda however i
offer gears of war judgment as a worthy
contender for title screen and
theme music damn that song in the car
and gym every so often
lords acd uh laura's acd in chat no
doubt no doubt absolutely we all caught
up and i wanted to shout out replicant
who had got that uh
merch we definitely want to shout out my
salute to get in tonight
i've been putting codes in the chat in
case you guys ain't been paying
attention
thanks to butterball he's also a fan for
i think since day one absolutely good to
see people we got a lot of overlap we
talked about yeah we got a lot of
overlap that's dope man
very cool to see so look man just real
quick the the podcasting you know what
i'm saying obviously
the component of what you do now
obviously the best game
best damn game podcast you got that you
know and then obviously you got one more
and then
um obviously defining duke with mr
maddie play so like
how did that how did all of these
podcasts start to develop and then
obviously lincoln would last stand media
and those guys as well
yeah i won't uh i won't extend the time
too much because i know that we we
have ten so it goes six hours but uh rio
basically the podcast is just me talking
about games which i've always wanted to
do and the patrons were a part
i was like hey that's a positive for
them because we can have
we can have patrons do something so they
all came
and we did the podcast and that's how it
started and then silver
and red who've been there since day one
with uh gb he's no longer there but they
were just like
should we just do a weekly one and i'm
all for doing as many as possible so i
also do two secret ones
no one knows who i am it's awesome yeah
no one's found out by the way really i
think some yeah yeah so i do
i do now i do six six or seven
uh uh podcasts every week and two of
them no one knows about
but i mean they don't recognize you they
don't recognize you they don't it's not
it's not game
related oh okay okay it's not game
related it is me though
wait wait you're guessing or you're
holding him co-host steve i would say
now
so it's it's enough that people at some
point somebody
will find out but basically i think
podcasting is awesome i think it also
allows for you to extend the discussion
of a game that doesn't get handled in
the review
it also allows water for pogba oh we're
going to be searching we're going to be
scouting right
now
and um and talk about games that maybe
have been patched
so like a no man's sky i may not have
time to review but you can certainly do
in a podcast so that's important
mr maddie plays he said hey i like your
fallout 4
twitter or on twitter he said i like
your fallout 4 review
and that's how that started now we're
best friends like i consider him a
actual like in fact i stated a couple
weeks ago on twitter
if i leave youtube tomorrow and the only
thing i get
out of it was meeting and knowing mr
maddie plays
meeting total biscuit jenna i like him i
like that i would absolutely be able to
walk away
and be like that was that was worth
those five six years those people are
absolutely worth it so
and that we just started we liked each
other like he's a little younger but i
talked probably like a
three-year-old so it was this weird
dichotomy of
me being the way i am and him being the
way he is and then uh last stand
an xbox podcast was needed and i love
the idea of focusing on one platform
even though i love all of them
yeah and i hate them all at the same
time but it was awesome they were like
do you want to do
just a podcast where you have to think
about one thing and i'm a huge fan of
thought
like of trying to figure those things
out and almost thought projects
yeah so i was i dived on to that and
that's pretty much how we got here
absolutely man
love the energy again raw honesty love
how you give things extra time from um
from a game standpoint as far as talk
about playing games and
and the whole mechanics behind them and
obviously yeah i caught you on defining
duke as well
i love maddie turned into one of my yeah
it's one of my regular rotations it's in
my regular rotation
you can tell yeah yeah right like maddie
and i are
just i love when you attempted to swear
jar i love it it was like it was like
one of those
that swear jar was gonna be a thousand
and maddie
i love maddie but he cares and i don't
so maddie
will be like oh people are bothered by
cussing i'm like i don't care
at all and maddie is like the hug and
i'm the push away from the bad thing
and maddie's like let's do this he
didn't tell me he's just like let's do a
swear jar and you can
see your face dude i control nothing my
mom and dad like
they know not to ask me certain
questions because like here we go here
we go
like here we are because i'm just gonna
be like okay what you asked
and that swear jar was a disaster man
that's one of the few episodes i
actually
watched as opposed to just listening to
listen to it you gotta
see his face when he mentions the swear
jar because it's like
uh uh yeah what you know what's funny is
because first of all
salute the little acg for like 15
minutes
cause what it is you see it it is fake
it's an internal struggle
and i asked for first of all respect you
brother for coming on and respecting the
realm because obviously you know
i think here but it's so funny even when
you were in your natchez and you guys
tried to implement that
and it's classic um oh and you can see
me stuttering
because i am definitely a freebase
talker like let's go
two hours and instead maddie's like
let's control everything you say
i'm i'm like but friggin and i'm like
that doesn't sound
cool that doesn't sound and i've had
people be like you cuss too much and i'm
like no i cuss exactly as many times as
you hear
i don't because you know my kids watch
so but yeah yeah and it's
cool i think that's awesome but in my
chat if you jump in my channel yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah be prepared yeah yeah yeah you're
like
he's homophobic he's xenophobia he's
phobic phobic phobic phobia
he's racist he's all types of things but
i'm not i'm just
good i'm just having really much so much
fun but you know understand if you stick
around in the chat long enough to
understand oh he's just a normal weirdo
normal weirdos are not currently as
as acceptable as they used to be and i
think that is unfortunate
which is also i say what i want to say
and if somebody comes at me i'll be like
yeah but yesterday i said the exact
opposite
i had somebody get mad at me about
joking about a dojo wall hanging
oh my god my wife by the way chinese
salute
and so like it was weird to have
somebody call me racist because i said a
dojo wall hanging i'm like dude that was
my dojo jackass
i actually put that up like that was the
joke was that i put it up
and it was for shadow whatever the duke
nukem style game the shadow ninja
is that a warrior shadow warrior and it
was it was that thing where it was like
you are looking
you are actively looking for probably
something to be offended
yeah and there's true offensive things
man you absolutely
like that kind of that stuff but we're
the most progressive we say we're the
most progressive
like forward thinking entertainment in
the world
but we're not and one of the reasons why
we're not is because we have
all these people who are able to control
things and you're just like
that's slowing everything like it's not
looking at the real issues
right i mean there are some real issues
that whatever the reason why
i i'm in love with the last of us too
because it just did what it wanted to do
it did the hard things
it's like just when you thought it was
going to
like shy away from certain things it
didn't
and it wasn't apologetic about it at all
and
the difference between that and other
games
is just when you thought that one topic
which was taboo
was the tipping point was the it there's
another topic
yeah that is going to be equally as
offensive to somebody
or make you as uncomfortable while
you're playing the game
and test you morally and thought the
thought process
in that game i think is just straight
genius neil druckmann yeah he's a genius
absolute salute man yeah tremendous
history
i love love hearing these stories man
this is amazing and um
real quick personal question because i
got to ask this because i'm a fan
salute to your merch brother somebody
better get over his teeth because i i
gotta give him
a warlord shirt fire love to design that
and
i want to show you all that and then the
second thing is um the history behind
the name
the angry centaur gamer i got i gotta
get history
it's a d name so i lived with a guy who
spoke
horrendous english claudio if you're out
there
it's terrible i lived with him
and he was the dirtiest person i ever
met he's a guy who would put on a pair
of levi's that looked like somebody had
actively attempted to like put them in
the hadron clip there was it was like
it was it was the weirdest thing like it
looked like stealth technology there was
just
angles when he put on his pants and he
was he was super dirty and one day i
come in that apartment and i'm a clean
like myself sort of militant even though
i don't have that ministry
i come in claudio's house is her room is
dirty and he has kool-aid and it's got
no lie man i love you claudio it's got
moss on it or more
no it does and i love this guy by the
way he's
he's the nicest dude in the world but he
just and i come in there i start kicking
his [ __ ] around
like with my feet oh my stuff the stuff
around and he goes
and he didn't know how to say what he
wanted to say so he's like you're an
angry what's the horse thing in dnd
he said you're an angry centaur roommate
and that became our
rock band name angry centaur roommate
became the rock band
that we put together and we did that for
years and then when i did the channel i
was just like i'll do this
that became too long and people thought
angry meant something which
admittedly i am angry but that's not
really a part of the thing so acg works
much better it's easier to say and it
causes people to not
like get stuck on the angry which i
think a lot of people are like
they don't see it all the time so they
get confused by the name dope dope
history red
tremendous gaming history love the
journey
love the podcasting everything is fanta
again the the the art style i mean
not the art style as far as just your
your style of reviewing you know what
i'm saying the way you break things down
is just tremendous man so i want to
salute you there
but i got to ask you the question we ask
all the lords in the realm gotta put you
in the hot seat i need lord acg's top
five
games or franchises of all time
so here we go all right first of all say
i don't do top 10 lists for a reason
because i don't believe in them
i don't i just absolutely don't believe
that i appreciate you participating um
but i will absolutely do that franchises
too
franchises would be okay
okay ignoring mass effect 3's terrible
ending yes
i actually mass effect i i've played
over 60 times the first one i played 44
times the second one that's when i
started counting
like i was a mass effect it was beyond
it was
unhealthy which one
people are wrong if they say i don't
care we have this just by the way
nobody will even talk to me in discord
so uh so lord acg on may
8 we're going to have a little debate
um podcast about
in honor of the release of the legendary
edition would you would you
like to join us that day i would i would
because
i love mass effect 1. and
so so anyway mass effect would be would
be high space harrier
space harrier uh is um one of the first
games ever where i bit through a
controller cord
oh my god get ready um yeah oh get ready
by the way was so bad it had a subtitle
it was like
it wasn't even get ready it was like
right right
whatever and like scooby doo even when
you died it's like
yeah you'd be like yes
and then 3d space harrier was the jam i
had the glasses i
looked like the absolute nerd that was
amazing so
fantasy star number one so the other
fantasy
hold on but i even know the music for
the dungeons
it was 3d by the way because back then
it was all 2d and to go into a dungeon
even though it was like one frame
perspective it was like one frame a
second
i'm trying to think of something that's
that's like a franchise or a
title that i play kotor i mean i don't
want to cheese
but kotor is my favorite game like
pretty much of all time like
um we don't even count how many times
i've played that because i there were
times where i was playing it and then
starting it
so i would like the in scene would come
yes
and i would just start it again and my
wife would she actually was like can you
please
understand um
so that's four and then
i would probably say
ori and that's
majorly for the art yes but or and the
music by the way gareth coker i had him
on my podcast to talk to him i'm like
dude your art
and so that's a little bit of a side
title and i know two wasn't as
prestigious but something about ori
lights my fires and or
like art that's art that's
playable art so absolutely tremendous
list
i got love for the for the fantasy store
one reference last
space let me address something in the
chat real quick i guess we're starting
to have spammers in the chat yeah get
them mods if you see someone spamming to
the point
no they're trolling get them straight
out of here no warning none of that get
them straight out of here yeah
awful days we ain't having none of that
you don't say and the final question is
one
past or present any generation
favorite console of all time
xbox 360.
that was just it was it was uh they had
the three
uh the three release thing bioware
bungie bizarre
and um when it was the racing it was
mass effect and it was um
it was halo that was ridiculous halo 3
is one of
still one of the most insanely technical
beautiful games as well as just playing
games and i think the 360 did stuff that
i just was not expecting
i mean every time something happened and
i get people like the ps3 but it was
also difficult to work
with yeah you talked to devs and stuff
and so you get these awesome games then
you got skyrim
which was just yeah unacceptable so the
360 was just
it was magnificent and i think it was
also about friends yeah that was a time
where people were still
like there was couch go up but there was
also you were finally getting into
online yeah no you nailed it because
again
it was the shout out to the the blade
system shout out to xbox live really
advancing
because remember it was such a
phenomenon with yog xbox
but then to now advance it you know we
got party chats we got all these things
at the hard drive advances
you still get all the great features and
then like you said like a lot of those
iconic games you know mass effect and
you know all these games it
it just kind of took it to the next i
remember gears being a good point a big
one one of my best friends
that i got that um was quote-unquote
racist
um from a call of duty because call of
duty was like oh that was when the party
chats was real
right that's what they could do no i got
what you're saying yeah not the party
chats but the
the game chat the game chat yeah and um
i got a ton of friends
from that and you know he's like oh i
got a black friend
and i'm like okay cool right but
i finally found out that did the barrier
isn't the fact that you know uh we don't
live in the same area
the barrier we don't communicate yeah so
the fact that we were communicating yes
that changed a lot of things yeah yeah a
lot of things happened and we will
actively look for each other online
and stuff like that so i thought i
thought 360 actually bridged the gap
yes in a lot of divides yeah absolutely
conversation conversation and
understanding is a remedy for ignorance
every single day
yeah yeah it just gotta happen it's also
a remedy for you just kicking that
person out of your life
yeah yeah if they in fact are that crap
you know but i think overall almost
everybody i know yeah once you start
talking to them
like people start to understand
admittedly i had that with total biscuit
like like i don't want to play that up
but there was like i was sort of coming
after him
and when i finally got to talk to him
like i was like oh i get it
like it was and i think that's sort of
what changed me a little bit after
like seeing somebody and seeing what
they deal with and what some people
thought of that person
and you're like that's not true so it
was very cool shout out to the living
flame he said i think there should be a
shirt i survived 360 chat
salute yes i apologize for osiris
joining the discussion just want to
shout out
cyrus joined this guy i apologize um
shout out to bitcloud he said um he said
he liked everyone thanks for he got a
classic tea
he said shout out to everything
everybody hit the like button subscribe
to the realm enjoy the show your boys
signing out love you guys salute yes
heal up brother
and then i believe electrocution died he
got a t what
he said shout out scoring a new exotic
chess plate salute corey hale got the
pull over
he had the cot one salute you already
know solve super chats and then they got
to get to these topics because they
killed us he's like i guess it's not
going to be a topic
i guess there's not going to be a sh
goddamn day
about gaming and we got to talk about
games on the show we have
[Music]
thank you just play say something say
something then we have neomental with
the five dollars if it's that episode
two hundo
yes congrats gentlemen salute thank you
my brother
then we got mods gaming with the hottest
of all tanks
mass effect one was the best despite
technical uh loads of gaming
very objective editors we're gonna have
to remove access to him from the website
do this
horrible take
then we have our brother lord portia
power with the ten dollar super chat
portion on 200 episodes my brothers in
the in the realm much love from
a seasoned gaming crew oh and glad we
can all agree mass effect oh
god with the map we got some extra heat
lord acg oh my god do you want to do
this [ __ ]
oh my god
yeah y'all definitely got a heavy hitter
on your side looking looking very dream
team-ish i would say yeah it's very it's
it's it's acg it's uh bill stillwell
it's hoglaw
yourself and uh
it's like the fantasy football where you
start to you're like oh man i gotta
i gotta go pull out some stuff yeah i
gotta go go i gotta go get some free
agents right there
look at chris brady yes yes don't worry
working order what else we got uh
lexication over the 10
super chat what was your xbox 360 zone
remember that
i think everyone picked underground
underground i forgot about
zones yeah that was a not safe for work
underground
no we all caught up i believe so yeah
all right no doubt that we got to move
on tremendous show we got to get into
these topics poll
last week's log net poll results are in
the people spoken to the question
which aspect of xbox backward
compatibility enhancement has you
most excited regarding game preservation
the winner of our four-way
ilp poll it's online as well at 38
percent of the vote
was more fps boost enabled titles
coming in next yeah coming in that
second at 28 of the vote was
i don't care until all those bethesda
games are added wink this is before the
announcement
and the coveted third place at 24
percent of the vote was add more highly
requested games to the group
and in last place at 10 of the vote was
more
resolution based increases so lord
addict you've been championing this fps
booster you seem to have been winning
this poll here it's your thoughts
what do you think sir i oh you that you
just say that i won that i don't even
say anything
you're never going to convince me that
having games run better is a bad thing
so it's it's never going to happen like
they're about to put fallout
4 you know i'd like fallout new vegas i
don't know if that's a realm of
possibility but you know maybe we'll see
that in the future
right there's all i need to know like we
don't even need to have that
conversation
no doubt so we are going to move on to
what we would guess i'd call
affectionately the main event here which
everyone has been patiently
waiting so um look man again i would
call it like a
tale of two different days two different
next
xbox wires so to speak you know and then
obviously we got on tuesday the official
announcement
you know as far as um the deal being
complete with the acquisition of
zenimax with microsoft you know but
that's the networks and all that good
stuff
so there was a statement issued at the
time it was like our goal is to give
these teams king's already starting
oh god he's already stopped
he's in his bag so he said a goal a goal
this is phil's on xbox wire's goal is to
give these teams the best foundation for
doing the greatest works and to learn
from as we continue to build xbox into
an inclusive platform for all players
then this was the key paragraph i felt
on tuesday which is this is the next
step in building an industry leading
first party studios team a commitment to
have with our xbox community
with the addition of these teams gamers
should know xbox consoles pc and game
pass
will be the best place to experience new
bethesda games
including and this was a very key word
here that got the internet into tizzy
some including some new titles in the
future that will be exclusive to xbox
so at that point there was a lot of
discussion whether these games would be
exclusive or not
which then led us to thursday and they
would believe
uh shout out to aaron greenberg there
was an announcement that would be a
bethesda
kind of microsoft roundtable in person
kind of get together kind of thing and
um yeah there was it was a key
statement here i got to read this one he
said um shot this is
again from how we call them uh uh king
lord phil
dominus maximus really is that correct
sir
uh okay i just want to make sure i have
all this time that you and we have um
i'll try to be as clear as i can
obviously i cannot sit here and say
every bethesda game is exclusive because
we know this
is not true there are contractual
obligations existing games and even in
the future there may be some
with either contractual things or legacy
another keyword
on different platforms that we'll go do
but
this is about delivering great exclusive
games
for you xbox customers that ship on
platforms
where game pass exists that is the goal
that is why we are doing this that is
the root
of this partnership so this also
set up a big flurry on twitter as far as
clarification
social media went crazy so before i
start because uh the realm
they're on me they're like uh you gotta
let king unleash
he's gotta talk [ __ ] stop your
playstation balance foolishness
so lord king i'm going to give you the
option to either having the floor now
or opening the floor before you go
oh you're going to open
the million it is indeed and i just
wanna
thanks for having me on cog i'm sorry
about last night i was waiting for your
text but i didn't get one
yeah brother cause i i was on actually
xbox and i sent you a message online
which
you yeah i were not i was wait i was
waiting for a text on the phone
brother just a miscommunication i'm
happy that you are in the room and i
will teach you how to rate i guess yes
she's my newest member of the
iop definitely i can't make
look at my look at his picture right now
i know he's doing the most
he's doing the most but look so look we
got randy first of all thank you for
making it brother
um this was a big one and and the reason
why i wanted to
start with either you or king first was
just that you know
rand you have been kind of well no i did
not give it to him oh i thought you gave
him
no i can't i'm here to hear king oh yeah
he said he said first he said i'm gonna
open that oh my i apologize lord king
your thoughts on these announcements sir
the moment that they acquired them or
they were in talks to acquire them i
told you what was going to happen
therefore that's why i got the name the
prophet
i told you we don't spend seven billion
dollars
for no reason but
games are coming out def loop king do
you know we
you had those deals in place phil said
i'm gonna respect your deal yo
you got a deal in place i don't feel
like taking you to court and stripping
you and doing
it's not necessary to do the rigorous
you want the game here have the game
yeah
you got it you're gonna get it anyway
it's gonna be in game pass right enjoy
it for the time that you get a chance to
play
enjoy and you have other legacy games
as well right don't worry don't fret
you'll be able to play those legacy
games so king j just just to
be fair people are saying legacy means
franchises
no that's not way about that listen here
a legacy is
when you play uh what's that elder
scrolls online
and you have a lineage with your
character so if the next dlc comes out
you won't be excluded you will be
included for a feed for a fee
sir you know if you're in game pass
there's no fifi
there's no fee for you you won't
understand what game pass feels like
oh yes you will because you will have to
purchase a lockhart
you will have to partake your knees
are giving up the bending has begun
and this is just the
appetizer this is just the appetizer you
saw 20 games just show up right boom
bang boom got it game pass
and i know you're gonna say king we've
played those games i've purchased those
games
that doesn't affect me what happens when
the new stuff hit
oh what happened when game pass gets
starfield you know that's coming
and you don't act like you didn't want
it because sony was trying to buy it
exclusive
see man creates his own
monsters maybe if you didn't go
looking for starfell and make it
exclusive
and wake the beast wake the beast
if they did this to themselves and
that's what we were implying they
asked for this they asked for this
gameplay
this is a spiteful response that's what
this was of a slice of the pie
and phil said you know what let me show
you how to do something let me show you
how
to cut somebody out of the whole pie i'm
going to buy the whole company
i'm not going to buy one aspect of the
company
i don't have what is it like going to
the strip club with dollar bills
i don't have dollar bill money i'm going
to the script club and buying the whole
strip club
and only my clan is inside this is what
that is
you understand this is the difference
you're going to the club and there's an
exclusive club that you can't get into
unless you're part of that group it's
over
now okay when those games start to come
in
and the developers start to you know the
wildest thing
phil said what he said that's nice that
we got them that's great
you know what i'm more excited about
that edtech
you thought halo looked bad you thought
certain games didn't look up to snuff
how y'all like that doom that doom
looked nice right good tech
yeah nice engine yeah so
who owns intech now who owns it
yeah there's a lot of possibilities
there i mean obviously
there was some hints like i mean
obviously they could go away from um you
know unreal engineers have options
that girl is shared
and what if phil don't want you to let's
say he says nah
it tech stays in-house only that's some
tech that you don't have
that you're not involved with like
you're not involved with any of those
amd full rdna
two features yeah at a point right now
this is the precipice i told y'all
before that i told y'all on boom show
let's go this is the last playstation oh
my god
really this is the last oh
you guys can't have a miss
you already started 20 million in a hole
oh my god she's already started 20
million games
that's the platform game pass is the
platform when it's on your team
oh yeah you're talking it's on your
phone when it's on everything
you have started 20 million in the hole
that's like saying we're gonna run this
marathon i'm gonna beat the guy but he's
20 miles ahead of me
i can't catch up now you're talking
about subscription services sir that's
right
it's over the fight is done the fight is
so fun the fight is done
you know when it you know when it really
happens you know when it really is going
to hit home
you know when the knees are really going
to just start rolling when jim ryan has
no other recourse
but to allow game pass as a streaming
service on that playstation 5
just to have life it's done
and you can click this you can put it up
and you can save it uh-huh
i told you phil was the right man at the
right time
everybody was telling me oh he's too
nice how nice is he now
who did that for you
and there's no and there's no denying
his name anymore there's no denying his
place
so this place is solidified just for
clarity this single move of bethesda has
already in your opinion crowned
victory for the generation there's
nothing somebody could do already
you know what they're going to do
they're going to do what they always do
a triple a banger yes put it out and we
love them
yes all right so the 10 buys it if you
have 125 million
consoles and only 10 million buys the
game
you're missing out on a whole group of
people okay
you're missing out on a ton of people
that are not purchasing the game
you cannot survive on that old business
model
you have to fix it and i don't think
they're in a position
right to fix that business model jim
ryan is willing he is complicit
complicit jim dance
he don't care he's gonna put your games
on pc he's gonna make money any way that
he possibly can
i just don't think with this much of a
head start
right and this much of the back and they
said they're not
finished what happens if they buy capcom
what happens if they buy sega that's
what you're all anticipating who they're
gonna buy
next who they go that's enough that's
not xbox money that's microsoft's money
that doesn't make any sense it doesn't
make any sense
i want to back track of what are your
points in reference to
um again there's been talk
that basically failed mimicking your
statement
in reference to the way to do it you say
like instead of
like he said instead of 14 or whatever
studios making one type of game
right um you know great game we want
this diversity of titles on the platform
we want
you know this kind of thing we reaching
out do you think because some people
have implied that was supposed to be
like a shot at sony as far as
you know how i go on the hashtag just
one with the third person
over the shoulder cinematic type
experience right and we know they're
great
they're awesome at that like that's
their bag right so do
you kig also agree with them as far as
people say like that
phil was kind of throwing a dig at their
style as far as
game development stuff like that for
from a studio stand before producing
those type of games
where they go in diversity is it a but
i got to say that sony is successful at
making these games these games are
wildly hugely successful for their fan
base
and why not cater to your fan base to
make sure that those titles are sold in
that matter
but what happens when you're a loser
right when you're a loser when xbox
loses
oh okay they are willing to do whatever
it takes to win right
you don't want to hear how much you suck
they said that we didn't have any games
right bingo is over right that part is
done
right we didn't have development houses
that was as strong
as sony's uh first party development
bingo
we have games development houses that
are on paul if not better
western rpgs is the home of xbox oh
factual everyone have to say that i
would like period they were
there they're in the talk they're just
trying to diversify their portfolio
going forward now i'm not saying that
sony isn't the king at the moment
because they
are right but the shot for that
crown is in jeopardy this is the part
where the crown is in jeopardy
and you want to look and see how that
champion will respond
to this ko blow will he get up off the
floor because he just got knocked down
in in the fifth round
and i'm gonna tell you right now the way
that phil is throwing these punches
you may not recover brother oh boy
this is going to be a photo i cannot
wait till we get to start responsible
look king's in his bag
i know we got lord randy i have to get
brad in next and then we'll get acg
but um lord ram you know obviously me
you've had this discussion i feel
ad nauseam for most will they won't they
are they exclusive what's exclusive all
these conditions all this stuff
with the events of this week what's your
thought process on everything
about the whole way things went down
um i i uh i mean none of this is a
surprise to me
i've been saying they're going to be
exclusive since uh the acquisition
in some september 22nd so anything that
ever made any sense
and for anybody that understands
microsoft and xbox's business model
annual recurring revenue would know that
uh
the whole idea of microsoft um
putting starfield or any of these games
on playstation and
taking that one-time sale isn't what
microsoft is in the business of anymore
right they want you subscribing to game
pass forever
they want you they want to convert
people into
you know customers were okay you want
these games you want these bethesda
games you want elder scrolls you want
star field you're gonna have to play
over here
and then you're gonna have to subscribe
like why microsoft's whole thing is like
why bother
basically selling you the game once when
they can sell it to you on game pass for
eternity
right and then you know you become a fan
you start buying your third-party
purchases
dlcs micro transactions and
this is this is a very nice way of
putting it but essentially
uh the those people on playstation are
worthless to a company like microsoft
in the mastercard okay of the single
purchase right yeah
um so this i i've been with king i know
you waffle a little bit cocky we're like
when we get to my part we're going to
talk yeah yeah even though even though
you know i've been telling you for i
don't know how long
i understand it it's it's all i will say
it's almost like
and solve what's the expression we
playfully use with snatching defeat
from the jaws victory i'm so used to
some sometimes yeah microsoft does have
mistakes like when they try to raise the
price of xbox live gold
120 like we get it sometimes they make
some pr blunders and
i understand people being like oh man
did they
are they really going to make these
games multi-platform
the minecraft example everybody points
to well they bought minecraft and it was
like
yes sure minecraft was everywhere
already
but this is this is different this is a
completely different beast
and this is microsoft's way of basically
changing the game right i would say
microsoft if you're if you're talking
about the way the console business has
always existed
right microsoft was never going to beat
sony at that
sony's just way too popular of a brand
especially overseas
right so what do you do well you change
the game you're playing
right so you introduced this disruptive
force
called game pass and it only works
if you have the backing of a
huge company correct and there was a
point in time we've talked about it
where xbox was kind of seen as a side
project
you know don matrick terry meyerson we
all thought
xbox wouldn't last very long with what
happened with the launch of the xbox one
right but as king would say phil dominus
maximus aurelius spencer somehow
convinced
satya nadella to not only keep xbox
around but invest more money into the
brand
than ever before right and here you see
they buy eight studios in 2018 they buy
another one in 2019 with double fine
they spend 7.5 billion dollars to get
eight studios at bethesda
right right i know we'll probably talk
about this later but
it looks like outriders is coming to
game pass on day one which
would be a significant addition
uh rumors are ubisoft plus has come into
game pass at the end of the year
that would be huge especially live
service titles continue yeah they're
making
moves and this is only possible with the
support of a company
like microsoft who honestly believes
that gaming is a pillar of their
business
right right so they're they're doing all
these things
and king's right they're not gonna stop
buying
companies they're gonna they're gonna be
buying more publishers
i'm not saying they're about another
publisher this year more than likely
next year
because they know that they need to feed
the beast that is game pass
right right so you need more studios
and this is exactly what xbox fans
wanted we you know
you've heard phil's and all of them have
heard the memes xbox has no games
that's true etc etc etc you
start this generation you have 23
studios
basically the way i look at it like
starting this fall it's just going to be
non-stop games almost every every other
month
like i've been saying for a while that i
think the lineup for this holiday is
going to be forza resin 5 starfield
and halo infinite september october
november
right and then you get into 2022 and
you're looking at like how blade two
everwild
wolfenstein iii um avowed
four's a motorsport and then you get
even further and further along and
there's just more and more games coming
and they're going to be games coming
like every other month for game pass and
that's the whole point
yeah and while playstation is amazing
and they are going to put out incredible
titles and those incredible titles are
going to be incredibly expensive
at 70 bucks a lot of people are going to
look at xbox and be like man they got a
lot of stuff and
yeah it's really cheap over there i can
get all these games that are coming to
this service for
ten dollars can i get a lock card
they got that perfect companion console
that xbox series s that is really small
and can fit right next to my playstation
5
you know you know what i don't even need
to buy hardware i actually have a smart
tv
i can actually get game pass on my smart
tv app and i don't even i have a dual s
a dual sense controller
and that already has support for xcloud
or
i even have a huge gaming pc right you
know like
you start to see exactly the vision that
phil and his team has put
put you know uh forward going with xbox
and you're like man maybe this
is actually going to change a lot of
people's minds
now obviously games need to be quality
first and foremost right
i'm not necessarily a fan of like well
just like
i love netflix because netflix puts out
a lot of great content but some of their
content is also horrible
right so for me i'm
hoping and i like that the majority of
the content that they put out is really
really good because that's what's going
to change
people's perspectives and narratives
about the brand
and everything um another thing i wanted
to point out was
essentially that there's this talk that
oh
xbox is abandoning the 120 million
playstations yes yes
yeah that's not true it's a new
generation
starfield is a next gen only game you're
not
abandoning as many people as
everybody would have you believe you're
not abandoning 120 million people
at most when starfield comes out
playstation might have
you know seven eight million consoles
what have you so it's not as
it's not as big of a deal as you'd
imagine right and then the whole legacy
comment
i the people that keep on pointing to
that [ __ ]
legacy legacy they hold it a lot of
people hold on to that except
for talking about it as the like legacy
software legacy versions of windows like
old stuff that exists on a platform that
will continue to get updated
all out 76 you know the games that are
already there will continue to get
support that's what legacy means in this
contact
uh context and future in future
contracts like
you know we know death loop and
ghostwire tokyo yes those are on
playstation
indiana jones more than likely probably
has a contract in place
beforehand um but i just i just i just
want to give a shout out to
all the fake insiders there's a lot of
insiders that were
that were honestly saying that you know
they talked to people and you know
everything was staying the same
you know and and these games would be on
playstation 5 and all that stuff
and uh yeah it's it's it's a great week
it has been an interesting week for sure
i can't wait to hear what actually yeah
we're about to engage i'm a huge fan of
been a patreon for like three years
i love his content so thank you can't
wait to hear what you said absolutely
just what a shout out really quick lady
gina reigns aka
lord dizzy's mom just bought a classic
tee put the crest up also yeah please
man put it up in there for lord dizzy
mom appreciate you listening and again
much love
we appreciate the support always going
to celebrate our brother lord dizzy have
to say
so that was that um lord acg um
got to get it to you next because um as
lord addict said i believe
when um tuesday hit there was still
i want to say a debate there was still
enough language
that people on both sides were trying to
defend their position or whether whether
or not these games are going exclusive
so as the week has gone on and and as
lord said
he watched your twitter and you were
holding the line so to speak
you know what i said so i want to give
it to you brother with the events of
this week and how everything planned out
what are your thoughts on this whole
thing but that's exclusivity
to microsoft so every time i speak now
i suddenly end up on a website
so i want to watch what i say because i
do
there there is there's a reason why i
was saying what i was saying
last year and that's because there are
certain people that like i do talk to
and are it's not me so it's like i don't
want to take
that there's some people that are very
cool and they tell me some stuff and
that's turned out to be just impeccably
right which is
weird because usually you get like a
leak and you can tell it's like one
person pretending to be five people you
know
perfect yeah you know trying to leak to
you um so i'll just say that all this
turned out exactly
as the rumors were portraying
um the legacy thing the easiest way
to look at legacy is to look at how
microsoft terms so
pr is my background so microsoft terms
legacy please help me understand this
yeah so their terms for legacy include
windows
and how they term legacy it also
includes office and what switches
they've done legacy does indeed mean
those things that have already existed
and are continuing on currently
right so so the people who are using
legacy that's just a stage of grief
and it's it is okay but and i get it
people don't like it remember
this is sony has a playstation because
nintendo and sony tried to work correct
people don't know backstabbed each other
and first of all i don't believe in
holding any i hate and like all the
companies first of all they're not
saving babies from floods
so you should not have i really truly
believe you should have
absolutely no loyalty to any
company and the reason why is they have
no loyalty to you
they it's a it's a it's a business
transaction and that's fine
and you could want wanting is different
than loyalty yes
correct that's it's a complete different
thing so when you look at this
it's it's exactly what i think anybody
who watched business
expected and uh i don't really have a
ton to add
other than microsoft and the way they're
going
is more towards so somebody brought up
platforms
and phil's stating platforms what
again pr if you track every single pr
statement microsoft has had which i do
and we we cut them out and we look at
keywords right microsoft did not mention
during that same discussion mobile yes
the reason why is because he meant that
when he said platforms
and so people thought it meant sony you
have to look at what people
don't say especially a ceo
or what they can and can't do they're
not elon musk you can't say dogecoin or
dog coin all the time without getting in
trouble
like they can't right they're going to
get in trouble if they say certain
things and so
what he did and what he said that was
pretty clear to me and
it's fine also i got to say again the
gatekeeping thing yeah
fix your terminology because you're
wrong your language is wrong if you're
using gatekeeping to discuss this uh
especially because we're talking years
out and now
this will be like rare where whatever
rare makes you can't blame on nintendo
you it's it's them together and it's
what they make whether you like it or
dislike it that will be bethesda as well
also some positivity here i'm so
freaking tired of companies
doing stuff the 10 cent investing all
this kind of stuff
and it's always negative here dude look
at that meeting again
it's a bunch of people who like working
together yes that's what i love
gaming holds hates like dwarves and
warhammer
like like books of woe gamers will be
like i remember 20 years ago
when blah blah blah you know okay but at
some point these are people who like
working together you can tell they like
working together and they're excited
about working together
move on also people will replace
bethesda
people tr double a developers are at
some of the best
some of the best places they've ever
been vampir
is focus focus interactive is a
publisher that is like
absolutely knocking out of the park they
are like plagued tail innocent oh yeah
all these kind of games right oh man
they will
end up taking those spots and
it's it's okay man like it's i don't
know why
they need a hug and it's like dude look
outside
people's lives are ruined right yeah
facts this is people
liking to get together they're
rewarded by the way america in
particular loves to
celebrate you when you do well and then
hate you when you're doing well
that is that is absolutely western
culture and it's like instead you know
what
they're getting together they like
working together and they're gonna make
some cool stuff and that'll give
other people for sony by the way who
will be shopping
yes sony will be shopping and king was
right
uh when when sony is looking at
starfield exclusivity and i stated this
at the start of the podcast
you can just say microsoft needs to
follow rules nobody else follows
and they're like okay we'll be honorable
when no one else is
not the way it is man it's not and the
platform smart tvs that's for sure
happening
samsung yes lg they've already announced
their stuff
they've already got their deals and
instead of sitting here
and crapping in your own bed and being
unhappy all the time
you need to sit there and say what can
they do and let me just real quick we're
doing a podcast for two hours and all
we're going to talk about is a mixture
of these companies together
right what if you get elder scrolls the
real-time strategy rise of empire style
that's ridiculous what if you get elder
scrolls an
x-com like style or a wasteland 3 style
but with elder scrolls
there are all these ips where people are
finally going to get to say
let's work together oblivious or
obsidian obsidian
in bethesda it's crazy to think and
admittedly there was some blood that's
gone
yeah by the way yeah but there was and
them to come together is great there
there are a lot of people who sort of
say that they know
what's going on there's there's a couple
secrets i will say
i unfortunately do not share the
positivity that
that ran and was saying about uh the the
number of releases
okay okay uh kovin from
my sources is that covet has annihilated
development got you uh microsoft is
better because they already did a lot of
remote but the teams that they are
bringing in some of these teams did not
gotcha and as somebody who has set up
companies
for working remotely that can push you
back three four months
so i agree that we'll see a lot i just
don't think
especially next year looking at how
things are going right
you know what we'll see also this thing
about third-party or third-person
games yeah sony rocks at them but i'm
going to tell you right now
let's say it's a long game let's say
it's 80 hours of the best spider-man
you've ever played right
that's once every three to six months
what else are you playing
and at some point you look at game pass
and you're like well this is what else
additionally microsoft sells their
consoles for a payment price which
during covid does help
so if somebody wants to pay 19 bucks
they can get an xbox right
that's ridiculous yeah and so that deal
is something we are
entering a value proposition moment in
gaming
i i want to i want to double back
because you you made phenomenal points
i mean what do you think for the people
who let's just like you said the five
stages of grief right it is there
you know they accept this they're on
like the second step
the anger the impression i'm seeing
people go through the whole five stages
go back to one yeah no i've seen it too
i'm sitting there they're still not like
dogs return to their vomit man
excuse my excuse my term they do by the
way if you own dogs like i do that's a
dog term
they return to their own vomit and
that's what people are doing they're
vomiting it out they're going through
the stages and they're returning back to
it and just
but what why do you think and and rank
you and rank and answer like why do you
think there's so
much anger or opposition to
now accepting that these games will be
exclusive like is it a thing that they
do you think that they had no intention
of wanting to get into the xbox
ecosystem
like why the resistance because the
right reason why i'm asking at attic
we've talked about this at nausea right
where we like yo sony got that final
fantasy 7 remake and i'm not hearing
when xbox is going to get it or
when street or whatever right we just
play station entirely
we're going to go to the playstation i
got an answer for you all right
we want to go where the games are right
so it's like i just don't
understand i have to ask both of you
this and ran you since you started like
why such an opposition to it you know
what i mean
i said um okay i i think i said this to
you the other night
a lot of its entitlement a lot of people
feel entitled to
all these games especially playstation
fans because playstation fans
have if you go back and look since the
start of the playstation one
uh playstation has normally gotten
everything like a lot of people have
just invested in the playstation and
gotten the majority of all the
third-party titles
and then when sony started putting out
their first party stuff if you're an
xbox fan you've accepted the idea
that japanese support is going to be
extremely limited
right if you're a nintendo fan you
accept
what because look at why put the tomb
raider thing like one game oh yeah
if you're a nintendo fan you've accepted
that western support for
your console is going to be limited as
well right right those are just things
the fans of both consoles kind of have
had to live with since day one
inherently yeah but playstation fans
have always been like we get everything
we get the best japanese support
we get the best multi-platform support
sony's putting out these incredible for
like we get everything right and now
there's finally a scenario where
microsoft plucks a publisher off the
board and is like
that's mine now and now a lot of these
guys
who are normally used to getting
everything right are like
wait a minute this isn't how it used to
be right
and they're thinking they have they
might have to buy a different console
they might have to
you know go to pc or whatever but i
thought everybody had all these
expensive pcs and they didn't well i
mean you know i thought everybody had a
hundred dollar rig and thank you since
xbox games are on pc that's what i love
all that stuff but yeah but that's what
it is
it's entitlement they're just used to
always being one way
and now when things change you know
they're they're just
upset about it no doubt i want to get
back to low agg they would get an addict
itself
so actually like what what do you think
you do you agree with rand do you think
like you know what why
some a specific group is just so like
non-accepting
of it well i think the
specific group is also of the age where
they're
the most socially active on twitter and
stuff like that so you're hearing a
majority of those fans who've grown up
with that
and yeah a lot of it's entitlement i
think also sony
so nintendo can nintendo just real quick
nintendo can sell you nostalgia and make
you believe you're buying something new
like that's nintendo they've already
that's that's why
i mean it's it's insane like i'm
legitimately
i am actually impressed by nintendo's
ability to sell you nothing
you know it's and i like by the way i
love the switch i have a lot of games on
it
uh sony is the same way and they're able
to
enact a very intelligent pr program that
causes
uh an influx of loyalty
in those people as they continue to move
forward that includes them removing
backwards compatibility chips from the
ps3 and people thinking somehow it's
magically a good thing
like you will have people and you know
it's
this is not to be rude yeah but if he
hits you
he doesn't love you
but that is a that is an abusive
relationship
it is the same way if you're a car
company and you like them and they
suddenly start releasing lemons you
would move on
right but gamers have a tendency to not
and they like those
aged uh console series which i think is
great
but sony's just known as artistic even
though ori and
cuphead came for the xbox they will
never get i even stated this i was like
if orie had come out
for sony sony would be trumpeting that
and that's also microsoft's fault
and that's the last thing i want to hit
is that microsoft the reason why i
hate microsoft at points is because they
destroyed their ability to cause
nostalgia when they released one of the
worst
titles ever for their premier ip in
master chief collection
it was a failure from top to bottom and
they
if mario had done that people would be
like what
like it doesn't even work yeah it's
co-op but you can't go up you're like
what does that even mean why am i buying
this pos now it's gotten fixed
yes they screwed up and they are known
as a business company
first where sony's artisan right sony is
the bob ross
and that's just the way it is personally
what i say is i don't even worry about
this stuff now i'm like okay they might
like people might be that way my job is
to deliver you
facts context whatever about whatever
and hope that as you grow and see other
games
you start to look i think sony is great
at cultivating art concrete genie one of
the greatest games i've ever played
i it's it's it's amazing and i don't
know if that would have been on xbox and
i don't know if xbox would have like
alerted people right right and uh and so
they both have positives
right but microsoft will be remembered
like this forever microsoft has a bad
history too
hey man windows phone oh yeah yeah
what's that
what's windows phone soon i was i was oh
dude i bring up zoom in reviews all the
time when people leave audio logs
instead of like i still get like i joke
about audio logs and video games where
i'm like this guy decided not to defend
himself he wanted to record his death as
he died he's like
everybody i'm dying and you find the
zune hanging out there like that's the
thing microsoft is known for these dumb
things that they do they throw money at
stuff but this is something that they
will not
leave also everybody remembers phil
spencer did have
that talk with him uh with i'm sorry i
can't pronounce his last name and i
don't want to butcher it um from which
which person nedlia or what the guy
it took phil a week to explain why they
should continue doing xbox and that to
me is a different situation from a
different kind of leader even though i
love shane kim
some others that have come and gone and
uh there's something
about him where it took him he didn't
just say
because we're good there's obviously a
plan and it was a good enough one for a
multi-trillion dollar company to back up
forever
absolutely man spitting it spin fire and
you know if you think about it
if microsoft as a company would actually
said all right
we're spinning off xbox or selling it
their stock price probably would have
went up
because a lot of the investors did oh
yeah i would have helped them exactly it
would have helped them
now it's doing amazing like obviously
they had good thought because now it's
doing gangbusters but
at the time yeah it would have it would
have helped them you know
the reason why um the phil story is so
incredible
is because he came from the bottom of
the company
yes yeah all the way up to the top of
the company
and um you know xbox now let's talk
about microsoft talking about xbox
and um to to do what he did and like you
said to sit in the room
and to say well this is the business
plan right
this is what i feel it can go to and
this is how i can do it and let me prove
this part to you
and allow us to turn this ship around
because
like you said bad marketing can destroy
you
yeah you know the wii u got destroyed
from bad marketing
we did not know what it was right
but when you knew about the xbox one all
you knew was tv tv tv mm-hmm
right and
language like that enrolls and destroys
the fan base and then not putting out
games on a timely fashion and then
you're looking over at the competition
i feel that phil knew
everything that was wrong he watched he
listened he absorbed it
and he made a strategy he acted when
you know a lot of guys would do the
normal thing like when
one of the people that were in the
meeting
decided to unveil the series
he agreed oh you talked about the the
game awards decision to
do it yes yes that was a good question
yeah um
listens and reacts always always i think
what really helped in that regard also
is that if you look at game pass and a
service
um that's where microsoft is pivoted in
everything
yes of the past exactly yeah so it
you know it would it's their story in
that sense exactly in that sense i
really believe that it was kind
that part of the art the argument and
discussion i think was easy because it's
like this is
in line with what you've been doing i've
been paying for microsoft office office
365 as a service
for like for a damn near a decade
already right
game pass falls right into that the
ideology behind it is the same
and the moment he was able to sell it as
hey we can grow
gaming in this same way and we can
become pervasive
without necessarily having to stop the
quote-unquote competition in the
competitive space
and and like rand said and like i've
said uh multiple times you change the
conversation when you're losing
when you're losing at whatever the
status quo is you change the
conversation
right and sometimes it works sometimes
it doesn't in microsoft's case it seems
to be working and
working extremely well right engagement
yeah
look we're going to get into it i i want
to get um lord addict down because
obviously it was a big week man you know
a lot of emotion
this week look at attic me and you
talking daily
every time any bit of news drop is it
going to drop when is it going to drop
we're sitting there even red was in the
chat like we're going to stay up late
to see if this news is going to drop you
know tuesday morning or what have you so
lord attic man
after all this stuff this week what are
you feeling about all these
announcements man
i just want to say that i told you guys
how many times people went at me all the
time oh addict that's not happening alex
that's not happening
i want you all to turn around and walk
out the club because you ain't invited
like i get it i get it like and it's to
a point you know
people have definitely went on they
stands and you know
it is a fair assumption right to assume
that you know when you're not
looking behind closed doors you don't
have people telling you stuff that
like look that's a lot of money i don't
know what way they would go
right like you know look from the point
of microsoft
sometimes they'd be iffy sometimes
they'd be doing this
are you are you applying because it was
microsoft that that's what
the shade of doubt was they might not
make these exclusives is when you put
7.5 billion dollars if you're not
looking at stuff with a magnifying glass
i could see to a point where you would
assume okay maybe they are going to put
stuff multiplied
to get that revenue back quicker right
but you know
you know shout out to like you know lord
call it it's like look you know
all stuff like this there is a reason
why i would assume
people like you know colin would think
something like that right
and you know we got love for him he
actually owned it man salute to him too
for putting this and i'm just like you
know
okay because i even had i even had to
get on it said i was like man let that
man live like
he admitted he was he he was he was
wrong about it's like
first off people ain't doing that second
off like i said
that kind of logic it's it's not
something that i wouldn't
completely throw away like there is a
aroma possibility where they
spend that kind of money 7.5 billion
dollars and there is like
yo that's that's that's that's a lot
playstation brand just to abandon right
it's a big thing to do
and i can understand people would assume
that you know maybe they're going to try
to play both sides a little bit
but it's just like look man like you
know people came at me on twitter people
came at me on
on you know like first off i wasn't
going to name people but mooch you're
gonna have to hold that oh my god food's
gotta get this
damn because you told me
addicts from past experiences past
experiences how'd that work out for you
i gotta work out
salute the mood can i add something to
what you just said
yes real question that popped into my
head yes one thing that does bother me
um and again i do i mean i'm tracking
these things is for example sony did try
to buy the starfield
exclusive yeah and there's a couple
things that people are forgetting one
port
work does cost money you have two
development teams versus one
you got various other platforms
additionally what blows me away
and confuses the hell out of me is
people will say
sony was listen to the stupidity of this
comment let's go
people were saying that sony was gonna
buy exclusivity
but that microsoft would have to release
it on both platforms to get their money
back
think about how money works by the way
it is not a zero-sum game that is not
how it works
those two comments are not in any way
shape or form
in line with one another and that is
mind-blowing to me that people who said
that they knew what they were talking
about
or people that like supposedly cover the
industry and you're sitting there going
like dude
you can't that's those are actual
opposites yes you can't say that for one
company this would happen and for the
bigger company that could purchase sony
right now by the way
yes king is smiling they would magically
have to do it to make the money back
you know i love him right you know i
actually have a huge man crush on him
he's talking that big money talk he's
talking about you
you actually phil no he's talking about
you because you're talking about
millions that big money talk
is about that big buddy this is the
situation
and people don't understand that that uh
microsoft
and xbox and yeah they're the same
company they're i don't i don't
stop trying to separate the two just to
make your point mm-hmm
right because i don't separate sony from
playstation or sony from their tv bro
exactly right you know [ __ ] at this
point um listen
microsoft is looking past you yeah so
when you say
oh we have a 125 million you know
uh uh gamers and npd's
they need us sony needs you
make every last one of those individuals
go out
just show me one game that every
owner of a playstation goes out and buys
to make that company more viable
to have more purchasing power it's not
happening microsoft sees the same thing
if they have 80 million
xboxes out there 80 million people are
not purchasing halo
no but i can tell you that game pac oh
exclusive yeah hang on no i'm not going
to say what i was about to go
you would whether you go right here the
other thing
that is not under nda people are going
to be shocked when they
finally find out uh how many
titles and how much money companies are
making on games
but it was bad there's hints but
i don't think people realize exactly
what's going on on gamepad well no i
know they don't
uh until they won't for a while but some
companies are able to
there there's some stuff coming out
where some of this will be talked about
and i think people are going to be like
oh
i see but lord acg once again but lord i
heard game pass is bad for the industry
i heard that
you know these games are giving it away
and everything's a dollar and it's not
you know what that's a legitimate that's
a legitimate um
long-term poisoning of the well kind of
discussion
right that's a theology or not theology
i'm sorry that's a philosophy
kind of discussion which i have
absolutely no care to engage in i don't
care about philosophy of stuff i could
be dead tomorrow so i don't care about
the game in the industry
in like 50 years i care about today and
i've seen the gaming industry adjust
with sony backstab and nintendo and
we've got the playstation out of it so
to me
i think it's a self-writing industry so
uh
we do have micro transactions suck but
you get my drift we also have free to
play games that by the way
some free to mmos are incredible and
i'll throw the developer 60 bucks all
the time i'll be playing
mmo and i'll be like dude this game's
good i'm just going to buy a cape
like i may not even wear this damn thing
but it's like they deserve
some some cash and uh so i think there's
a
philosophical discussion that's fun
because it makes us sound smart
but it also if you break it down and
look at math it also makes this sound
really dumb in the in the moment
right and i just wish people would
separate those two a little bit more at
times
i think the biggest issue we have in
terms of just
people are so obsessed with being right
which you know i myself i have that
issue sometimes too
that like they don't see what's in front
of them you know what i'm saying like
we clearly had so many little crumbs
showing that these are going to be
exclusive it's unreal
and it's like the moment that something
happens
like you know uh the the financial uh
executive for microsoft said
well this is this is how this is going
to happen it's like they grab that
and they hug it they're like this is
what i'm going to use in every argument
from now on into the end of time
like and it's just like sometimes you
know
coming from the do with the attic world
mode right
now it's it's bigger than just you oh
look at it growing look at that growth
wow
look at that groceries man wow
[Music]
i know you guys asked for him you got
him yeah
like follow subscribe let's get those
likes up
acg is dropping now let's tell you right
now
i got a bad crush you talking that money
talk
he said his beanie's
better than mine which bothers me to no
end oh i need like i need a fancy i need
to fancy myself up bro
as my wife would probably
get some lord merchandise and show up on
the international podcast with your
stuff
introduce myself i'm just going to be
like what's up this is lord's podcast
i have done that by the way maddie has
introduced himself as carrick and i've
introduced
us you want people listening going what
is going
on i mess with people man you know what
uh lord acg what a what you know how i
know this passion and you like crazy
amount of passion like
you was about to say some stuff you
weren't supposed to say
yeah dude i leaked far cry primal a year
before
dude i got so i have a podcast where you
see me with cadiz and i'm like
what if there was a far cry game where
your caveman blah blah and then you see
me go
and kiss didn't know because i didn't
tell him so he's like that would be
awesome and
what if blah blah
and i left it up and luckily they were
okay with it but
yeah and that happens to all of us where
you'll you'll slip up and you'll be like
hey can you clip that yeah oh man i
don't say i know that feeling i
[Music]
yeah and i don't want anybody's thoughts
to permeate my brain
but we're at a point right now and and i
really want you guys to clip it out
because
i've seen companies come and i've seen
them go
yeah this is the pivot yeah this is the
point okay
it's knocked down and then you know what
what i do want to point out again is
i don't blame a lot of playstation
people what it is is that they're
putting their
their hopes off of what's reality right
like
when you it's like rant said they've had
everything they've had the best first
person they've had
a lot of the marketing they've had a lot
of timed exclusives they've had a lot of
marketing exclusive content
it's like to to think that you know
elder scrolls
you know starfield we don't know a lot
about starfield but star field
fallout dude you know wolfenstein
make die right but you can't say that
sony's this giant amazing publisher and
then say because bethesda was bought by
microsoft they magically have nothing
right like that's what bothers me
because i agree with you attic but it's
like i'm so bothered by people
complaining it's like dude you'll have
your own games yeah so
he's not gonna magically sony's not
gonna magically be like wow
all right day one we're done
let me ask you a question i see that a
lot of people that i gotta get some of
do you feel personally because of this
acquisition with bethesda
that sony needs to shop around for their
own students absolutely not and it's the
dumbest thing in the world
that's a topic that's a topic oh i
didn't know
right there right on the shoulder salute
to the co-host sony response is so
vague i don't know what you're talking
about oh my god anyway
we're gonna get to that soft thank you
perfect transition to you by the way
oh yo man so so this week man big week
you already heard what rand said you're
with achieving the server from king
and i um like what what was your
thoughts this whole week
the timeline with the exclusivity the
announcement then the round table
well yeah so i mean i i was with addict
and i was with uh
with with uh king the entire time like
you don't spend this money to give it
away to get a spending
to be the you know to be sort of the
messiah that helps everyone
i was saying last week i was like
because then people were like oh it's
going to be the little stuff you know
they're going to make
all the big stuff small types like the
little stuff they're going to make
exclusive
oh look so they spent 7.5 billion
dollars to give us the crumbs okay that
makes sense but that's
i mean you know what it is though i do
understand people nitpicking language
because
phil spencer as spencer is one to do
like
in in acg clarified this right because
let's start like on tuesday or what
monday or tuesday when they made the
initial announcement that it was
everything was set in stone the
messaging that day
i felt was still very non-committal i'm
just like wait a minute
they own them wholesale why is he not
being crystal clear
obviously they had another thing coming
down the pipeline later in the week
but i'm like and then you know acd
clarified that well he has to speak a
certain way right he has to be
and phil himself is very is a very
diplomatic person when he speaks he's
not going to be the dude he's like yeah
i got you
that no he's awesome actually he's not
that dude so for him to say
yeah i think you know i think these
games that are coming
to the you know the they're not going to
live anywhere but game pass so if that
platform doesn't have game pass well
you know a plus b equal c it's obvious
what i'm telling you
right um so then you know i i was very
fine with that um
and i think that is absolutely crystal
clear i don't think people
um sort of uh creatively taking the word
legacy and and
ending it in different ways and it's
legacy's legacy's old stuff like this is
ongoing stuff
you know um it's not happening it's just
not happening legacy
literally like people for some reason
they're trying to turn
legacy into like it's a franchise oh
because
the legacy title the french like rare
like people like legacy means fallout 5.
legacy means all the legacy ip like doom
and gloom
that means honestly beyond there it's
like you need to look at what the way
phil
phil talks about legacy what acg already
explained it's like
it's just software on you know old
software and a platform that will
continue to be supported
it doesn't mean the next elder scrolls
is going to be there precisely
but that's that's just one that they're
in the um what is it the bargaining
stages of the
you know five stages of grief
essentially i love what it is yeah we
need
shirts for each other i've already
designed the grief one
actually that we were gonna go live with
today but it's like i want to make all
of them
until right at the end it's just a dude
crying just
sobbing shoulders shoulder shaking
myself i even let myself believe maybe
they give them wolfenstein yeah
just cause it's like it's a sequel it's
a continuous story yeah
and they may do one right
but i'll tell you this i think the most
exciting thing
about this for me is that if you look at
bethesda's games right the biggest
sellers the biggest sellers
are their elder scrolls their fallouts
all the
all the games from the smaller studios
the tango game works the arcanes
those games are amazing and they never
got the same
shine as those other huge games yeah and
then when you look at them
making a deal to make an indiana jones
game it felt like it was a
moment like a pivotal like there was
going to be something of a pivot
in the way bethesda did business because
at the end of the day you want
your all of your games to sell very well
right um
so my thinking was man i don't know if
we get dishonored three
right i don't know if we get another
wolfenstein after three
i don't know if we get you know
something as exploratory as like
bringing back rage
or bringing black prey which i love
and i'm like i pray so if if they stay
on in on their own
i don't i think you start besides elder
scrolls and besides fallout i think they
make a pivot to
start making games you know that are
licenses and stuff like that
not fully and then live service and then
you see exactly what from
the young blood switch we've seen them
diving with the 76 like they were making
pivots because they were testing the
water
testing it feels like they're because i
mean
we i don't think we have any like
definitive proof on what these games
sold but
you know what were you laughing for no
because i'm thinking about when fallout
76
was this saturday thing and they had the
you purchased the server
and
the fact that now they can go back to
strictly being creators
yeah you don't have to worry about money
yes i'm
excited how excited i am what's their
excitement
out there yeah and you can see that and
like you mentioned before acg
like the you can tell these people know
each other for a very long time yes
they're excited to work with one another
um the fact that they're just
they're collaborating back and forth i
like i like the interaction between um
bethesda's marketing person and aaron's
yeah yeah
yeah you know what you know what the
part i like the most when
they're like we're gonna we're gonna be
scheduling something for this summer
she's like oh well once summer
officially ends
because the thing is they're not lying
to you when they tell you hey we have
stuff to learn from them
as much as they have to learn from us
yes and you know
they're going to learn how to market
yeah i knew that you know yeah tell me
about it right
microsoft and bethesda was mad close
like mad mad close
is when uh todd howard said that the fir
one of the first people he called
was phil what was was phil spencer 76
fiasco yeah yeah yeah and it
means just just just to say this this
week right here
with all these little snippets that they
have been throwing out
after the acquisition i believe that the
media teams got together to put together
these collages that will hit
and it felt like a bethesda hit yeah you
know when they when they showed you doom
what they showed you the name yep yeah
it felt
like those visuals was like whoa it
because let's be real all of us here
that have gone to uh fanfest
yeah and fairfax like we three bro but
has always done a great show you may not
like every game but as far as the
presentation and the way they
they galvanize their base to to go to
their show
it's pretty and microsoft will put you
in in waterproof
like things and show you the kinect
they gave us the popcorn remember that
that's cool like sitting there in the
arena
just not even the one with the drumstick
where i broke out in hives oh yeah i
remember that one yeah that was the
elder scroll thing where we had the big
the big meads oh yeah listen cause acg i
don't eat meat
right so i was at this point i was off
of eating meat for
probably two years at this time i got
there and i saw a flintstone
size the drumstick was like it was crazy
it was it was incredible and then he
gave you this giant thing of bear
right so i'm like you got to do it i
said please god
he got a cave man they had they had
it was it was the best they are the best
show on earth that's awesome yeah
[ __ ]
he was like they gave us free alcohol
free food
listen they have women walking around
with mini skirts giving hamburgers out
yeah dude if that doesn't speak to like
premier understanding is like hot women
hot men whatever you like handing
hamburgers out
even if you're a vegan you looked at
that and we're like screw it i'm gonna
get it
that's when you know their pr works when
they cause you to break a two-year
pattern there you go
yeah awesome yeah that's awesome
i wish i had gone you know the crazy
thing is like seeing
king's face when he was doing that like
he knew
he was doing something he was supposed
to do it
[Laughter]
i knew i messed up when the sheep's got
hard like because i was laying in the
bed you know the shoes are nice and soft
yeah i'm rolling around my god these
sheets is rough
in these sheets then i looked at my body
and said i'm a lizard
oh man that's rough yo so i'll finish up
but i'll jump right in
i mean just to end nobody should be mad
at this
yeah no one at all should be mad no and
the companies are going to fight back
too
exactly and that's what you want
everyone is fighting for attention
you know you know you as a gamer you're
in the best place possible so
uh nobody should be angry at this i'm so
excited about this and one other thing
yes uh i have to say pete hines
emceeing oh
xbox one day but i thought about it in
terms of
one day if phil decides to move on that
felt like
me yes that could take those reigns and
i mean and and no disrespect to matt
booty i don't know anybody a long time
no disrespect anybody but pete has he
has that presence
yes he ran a fantastic round table
yeah yeah there was something i just saw
him in a different light there yeah i
agree i i gotta jump in there
phil phil might be close to
putting the ice that the cherry on top
of that ice cream
and when it happens like cause i told
you it's gonna happen and you guys
laughed at me you laughed at me so much
and everything i'm getting the last
laugh this is the last one
the last one is game pass on that box
and that's the end of your box but
because i told you just press put an x
on it in his xbox
i'm telling you i think i saw
something in pete hines yes yes i saw
a aura of leadership yes he was
phenomenal let me just also been
really rough on him
for owning that i i admittedly maddie
is like close with them and i am known
on his podcast to be like i just don't
like him
i don't like the way he talks and what i
realized was i was wrong and what he was
doing was he was just being himself and
two people are not always going to agree
in the way they communicate
and i just i and that we mentioned that
in the podcast too we were like dude he
led it which is weird and it also means
there's a
companion yes almost like a partnership
you know
the old the old wonder twins
babies let's go i don't think most
companies would say hey you know what
we're the main guys why don't you run
the city
that's good so anyway starting right now
no no you're on fire you're
fine i like how when when they was
asking about the the summer
aaron's kind of like being cryptic he
was like he's not
answering the question he
spoke to the fan and what i love about
it is again
like you said addict like when aaron was
being corporate he was doing market
speak
he's like yo the people would know and
then it's like film you know
what's good aaron stop dancing phil what
does this mean to gamers like what's
going on
that the way rand i was loving this
thing man
like i i came let me let me get my balls
because this was a fun day it's a fun
week yeah go for it so pretty much look
like
like
soft said like we've always stood on the
square if you spend 7.5 billion
you know what i mean that these games
need to be exclusive you know when i
look at subscription services and i look
at like a disney plus which i initially
had no interest too much interest in
but then it's like okay you got all the
mcu films you got
mandalorian you got one division okay
now i have to have your service because
you have premium content
that i am now interested in so this
shout out to the fire engine going by
they salute to
week them week started up to me as a
clear case ran
of you know how the tweet of eagle like
how it started
how's it going now when tuesday hit
ran you know we spoke about this i was
furious
i was having to talk him off the ledge
like because like
no lie like monday when i monday or
tuesday i can't remember exactly
when the when the first inbound info
dropped i remember reading that
and being completely disgusting i was
like
as was i i was disgusted it was back to
me in that chat
oh yeah you were on your phone you were
like don't worry he said
just wait until thursday but the thing
when it was
king it was just like it was just way
too much corporate verbal gymnastics and
i'm just like bro
i have not learned anything
from the day you announced it to down
like i
i still feel i'm in the same position i
was in
is it because look at the language some
verb it was just
[Music]
the visuals that they put together they
had a whole package
no i
again shout out to the fire department
keeps going by what i'm
just like just like acg i also talk to
people
that know stuff yeah and i don't know
how many things i've told you in the
past have come out to be true you have
a lot of stuff i told you you did um
it's all gonna be it's all going to work
out in the end
red you're right you're absolutely right
but here's my frustration the reason why
i was
so angry is because to me
right i understand my acg is right
marketing you
i get it i know why i know the why but
to me it's like there's a lot of people
who have
it's a casual gamer right who has not
committed to either next-gen experience
yet
so to me that gamer needs to know yo
where is elder scrolls 6 going to be
where is fallout 5 going to be
right they need to know shout out to
these people going by with the fires
going on
but at the end of the day they burning
out here but at the end of the day
people it's fair to that community to
know where they're going to invest in so
when that went down okay i'm furious
then you hear about the announcement
they're going to do a roundtable right
and let's be real
immediately they set the expectation
extremely low
they were like don't expect no new news
remember greeny
don't expect this so now i'm coming in
like
and let's be real ran historically with
news and round tables and inside xbox
they haven't historically been some of
the greatest
things to listen to so i'm rolling my
eyes coming in like all right i'm just
going to listen to it
and we were talking like the the night
before it was like this is going to be
some game
yeah it's going to be some game pass
announcement it's gonna be some cringy
vibe or something
and i'ma roll my eyes and then i'm gonna
sleep so i ain't got a friend
i listen to the joint and again shout
out to pete hines
you can immediately see i felt the
bethesda
influence shout out to being in person
shows because we haven't seen those in a
while too right
where people were just in a room
together shout out to social distancing
i'm saying but they were in the room
together and just talking
and when pete got everyone to talk and
he
put it back to phil and then phil drops
to sermon so to speak
and i'm like oh wow they said it he said
it like
like you should have seen me when they
when they first initially patched a phil
it's like what's your thought process on
exclusives it's one of the biggest
questions we have i was like
here we go so for me i'm like oh
phil actually said it right now
we have clarity you know what i'm saying
now like
you can't really mince this you know
with gameplay platforms with game pass
exists and i'm just like
okay you know what i'm saying and it was
just well done so again
like lord acg i'm looking at twitter and
then you see the five stages of greece
with certain groups
you know they're just like not really to
accept it but look at the end of the day
those groups it was so much worse
because three days ago
they thought they had a victory they
thought everything was exclusive
i mean everything was multiplied it was
gonna be some games
and then it's like microsoft kind of set
a lot of these like
like uh like really really hardcore
playstation fanboys that attack me daily
like set them up to fail because on a
monday they're telling them some games
and then it makes people automatically
assume the worst because it was a
cryptic
wording and then on thursday they're
like yo everything exclusive if it's not
game pass so i'm like
it was it was a good day man it felt
like traps yeah yeah facts
look at the end of the day like i said
it was phenomenal to get the clarity
just to see the rejuvenation the
excitement in the xbox community
because you know they're seeing the
future is bright you're seeing these
great then when you start watching the
show
and you remember they did have a great
relation i remember getting the og xbox
with morrowind right and you start
hearing the story stories you know
i remember having oblivion then you hear
you know todd talking about how like
like oh you know like
alex said you know going the field
during the fallout 76 asking for help
you get excited about all these
possibilities from id tech
orion cloud just collaboratively i think
sponsors game studios right i think
working with the best
thing that i'm more excited about is the
fact that
now it used to be bethesda worked with
each other to or to work on bethesda
things like i didn't know that
you know the people in the eve uh the
evil within i can't forget
that studio name bingo is that tango
they made a demon and yeah and doom like
yeah like that is the kind of that's the
kind of collaboration i want on
microsoft on all things absolutely and
it just
to me and actually you can get this
reference like again i always use the
analogy of sports team it's like the big
free agent acquisition
and now it's like okay you get to work
together y'all in the dojo
you're practicing together like whatever
skills that bethesda has
the other xbox game studios can learn
and vice versa so this is great
collaborative energy and you could just
i love that ac
boom oh hey throwing up the grass let's
go
i wasn't ignoring you guys i was like
how do i find just
the the newest lord in the realm
lord acg yeah continue this
you know what i came to i akin it to
when um bruce lee was uh doing
uh what was that uh was it the game of
death game of death
and he got a chance to work with so many
great artists at one time
and they were uh sparring during the
daytime and you hear all the wonderful
stories
uh these people learning from each other
and collaborating with each other and
learning different moves with each other
i i think that is going to be a synergy
from that point yeah but
when phil said i'm so excited
with tango games yeah yeah and i want to
i can't wait to get to japan yeah
that's when i was like and you could
tell because phil
has been so hard work at like the
japanese market and trying to
you know have more influence over there
and trying to like have you know
correct a lot of to ships in the past
that like
i'm not saying that he didn't care about
the other ones but when it came to tango
in particular he's like
he's like finally we have some form of
studio to give that demographic the
games that they want
right no absolutely and like i said
final points again it was just fantastic
i love to see how excited
they were and as a person who loves tech
and loves to see you know people working
together
the future's bright the future's bright
looks good it was cool and again to the
laws of denial like rand said we we we
we we've referred to contractual and
legacy titles and we've we've got that
clarity and like acg said in reference
to
gatekeeping you know what i'm saying if
if ferrari wants to buy that exclusive
seat right little acg
exactly it's on them man just go get a
ferrari
for sony and nintendo and what they do
because like
raven rabbids is probably one of my
favorite games of all time yeah and
that's nintendo
right and that was them going hey let's
do a ubisoft joint
that to me is like you know awesome
rappers coming together
yeah i mean like let's do something
together right and musicians right now
which seems to be
the more socially distant everybody is
the more they want to work together
and it's almost like whenever anybody
says that they are an introvert they
really aren't they just want to be
invited so they can friggin say no
what's going on now with music stars is
they're like let's do it and i think
these guys tango is a weird name for him
to call out
i like that he did like that he wasn't
you know i wish he had said pray two was
coming but
we can ignore that for now i'm just
i mean no i mean like
i just can't wait to see them do it but
also so that people don't think it's
just
xbox there are other uh smaller
companies that i know that i talked to
just yesterday who are very excited
because they might be able to work
with a sony or a nintendo yeah get into
that and get there
and get into that space yeah because you
know it is instead of
people looking at it as a void now of uh
you know games
oh these games won't be there this is
going to incentivize
those other companies right now to push
those titles up i always felt
during the first infancy months of a
console release
the indie titles and the lower and i'm
not going to say like lower chair
the unknown uh developers
have to have platoons jump in and get
seen yes right and if you got that title
that hits
that pushes your company forward then
you can make a name for yourself
and i think this is a time where sony
goes out and and purchases
a couple of little uh uh development
houses to bring those in because i've
been watching
the um the asian market right and
these games that are coming out from
over there these the
the chinese oh bro wukong and on that
these games are peaking my interest and
i'm like wow
somebody's going to purchase a hell of a
developer
that is sitting there crafting right now
at this moment
and we're going to get some phenomenal
games but yeah it was fantastic um
i want to shout out a couple people like
someone else oh shout out to anonymous
sure donald
gotta unicef very soft you want to get
to see what's going on we got a ball
today yeah
we gotta go we got a ton and we got to
move over to the next time we got and i
gotta eat yes
long podcast acg was spitting balls but
i couldn't stop that good gaming talking
earlier it was just too good
i gotta let me roll back because i have
it all here okay oh
good it's all good mm-hmm we got a lot
going on while you're doing that
slapped everybody in the chat man okay
i'm i got it okay cool
no you wanna you wanna go ahead no no no
no so we have citizen sleeve with the
five pound super chat
sup lords first time watching your
cracking podcast absolutely
awesome to see my man carrick with you
much love and i'll be a regular viewer
from
now on thank you thank you thank you
then we have lady erica for the win five
dollars
salute lords great show and guests love
hearing the passion for gaming from acg
absolutely
couldn't stop that talking
then we have qti grizzly with the 10
super chat content lords
content then we have snoozle
with the two dollar super chat do you
all think death loop is going
on pc game pass interesting yeah yeah
but will it go on pc i i think the
question is we get a question that
elaborates on it a little bit
further down but it's is it can it come
day and date
with the playstation release because oh
no no no i think that
once it that timed exclusivity comes out
that's when will come to game pass and
pc game pass like you've never known
though
you never know there's been evidences
where xbox has actually gotten around
that
before because it's not on a complete
competition so i mean i don't think it
will but
you you don't never know yo rand you
know what that would do to me
what would it do what would it do to you
he's gonna play on his pc
i would play on my pc that day it's
savage yes so i can make a video
oh my god where are we going i mean i'm
gonna play death loop on ps5 because
i love arcane they are such an
underrated developer
i'm not waiting i'm not waiting i mean
it'll come the game passes the following
year but i need to play that game
i can wait a year i got a lot of content
you got a lot of content
yeah this is the super chat i was
talking about bay area with the five
dollars which had since death loop is a
timed exclusive yeah
any chance that death loop launches day
one on game pass pc and x cloud so
we'll see um we have urban ninja five if
we chat sony
was buying the eggs microsoft bought the
farm
that that means death as well so i don't
know if you maybe
true then we have king one supreme five
dollars which at king
i just got playstation five played the
five hour dlc in miles and now there's
nothing to play you were right
sony stands gonna cop the lock because
they got tcl's
oh my god tcl tv shaming once again
uh that was gone for a while too
yeah thank you kid welcome
then we have the wise old game oh super
chat
i hope you're feeling better brother i
know you've been going through some
stuff hopefully
let's just see every time we see you we
happy to see you in here bro happy to
see you
i've survived pain and death to be
witness to this day king going
ultra instinct it's as if microsoft has
gone from megatron to galvatron
oh wow wow
blast the base with the five dollar
super chat sony absolutely did
did to this did this to themselves by
trying to starve its direct competition
of content from third-party partners you
reap what you sow
thank you competition is competition
this petition is good
what else we got daniel with the two
dollars super chat mario back there
cheering and hyping king up
let's see what he's all about right get
him
what else we're getting and we have our
brother everborn saga oh
happy 200 lords and i hear all the mass
effects one versus two took but i might
be team mass effect three
oh wow okay yeah he did say that he did
uh shout out to the green colors and the
yellow endings and
adding a dlc afterwards to
also a question for king what is the
inverse of first
and best oh my god what the inverse last
the worst last
jim dance moves ryan ain't got the quad
strength to keep his knees off the
ground
oh my god oh wow wow
oh my god the wise old gamer once again
five dollars that game pass requires
frequent games sony does not have the
money to make this happen
their devs take three plus years to make
games sony would be a special niche
um they have the money to do oh they did
well we'll get into that in the summer
their own ceo said they would niche
oh my
are the only people i support on patreon
oh wow thank you
thank you wow we have a lot of roughness
roughness i love it guys
i make no apology and agree with king
this generation is done
and won it's oh damn damn
it is over y'all need to stop
subscribers you might as well just pack
your playstation
listen i already told you if if
game pass is launched on playstation i'm
going to dig a hole in my backyard and
throw my places
stop
[Music]
if you don't have it you gonna get it
hashtag xbox has games
[Laughter]
because of game pass me and my boys are
all going to start playing fallout 76
today
you don't need to convince friends to
buy games when they're on game pass yes
good points it is a fantastic
interest oh dang
that's awesome have you put it on before
yeah like does it actually fit oh that's
the fact that rand had to explain all
this stuff anyone with a lick of sense
would have known from the start
it hurts my head thanks for being blunt
thank you rand for helping everyone
through the stages of grief
you've been phenomenal for the past
couple of weeks
then we have eagles fan with the two
dollar super chat what do you guys
expect to hear on the 26th
xbox i think that's just going to be
like an xcloud thing
mdk nothing i mean they'll have some
indie titles but i
set your expectations for like the
extreme bottom of the floor
okay that'd be one of those things where
you don't even bother watching it you
just wait for
like updates you know after i'm reading
acg's face he's got the exclusive what's
up
you know act tell us
see i can see the clip on a website
where it's like i know it'll be like acg
with and
sometimes you'll just say something like
yeah you know i like black socks more
than white socks sometimes they'll be
like
carrick's saying and you're like
we try to get that clickbait popping man
how did you
how did you like that i gotta thank you
because you have gave me content for my
youtube channel
oh well there you go that's good there
you go there you go at least you get
sourced
acg because whenever we me and jess do
stuff and drops things it's always
jazz courses they don't give rand no
credit
some other dude was on there too and
jess said and it's like i said that yo
what's happening
there we got lucius augustus with the
five dollar ship attack
it's so crazy that the same people who
don't want xbox to have exclusive games
never said anything about street fighter
5 final fantasy 16
etc but phil did bridge phil did
not like that street fighter move oh
yeah yeah real though man i i need
i need better for microsoft with those
square enix times hopefully
we'll see moving on wait okay oh
exclusive
hold on everybody focus
acg with the exclusive continue
and we have adam with the five dollars
that even more logic both companies
won't release games because consoles
aren't out in mass yet
yet they need sony to make money back
that's true that is actually correct by
the way
yes yeah just so people know there are
companies holding back because the
current
uh issues with sales you don't want to
sell to one percent of such a small
group
uh a ratchet and clank a long time ago i
believe
such a good game yes i cannot wait for
that game
my playstation will turn on oh my
goodness
that's drop yes
michael aka pet styles minus five
dollars
if forza horizon chooses japan for its
next setting the fans are going to lose
their mind as well as me
this will be an epic year honestly yeah
that would be i mean if you look at
japan
just just the the colors and like yeah
cherry blossoms yes by the way remember
when verizon was announced and we were
all like
oh that's interesting like what is that
what is that and the best racing game
i love it speaks to my soul because i'm
not a motorsport
exactly between the two of them yeah no
doubt get us off
then we got michael aka size finance
again the 500 chats
episode 300 from the lords needs to have
phil spencer on that one let's make that
magic happen i would like for him to
show up on july
2nd oh that's my birthday
sound to philadelphia it would be an
honor to have phil in the room you
already know absolutely
then we have regulator with the two
dollars with chat happy sunday to the
lords and panel be safe guys
much love thank you thank you as well my
brother uh regulated once again with the
2000 super chat my opinion on legacies
remakes and remasters makes sense
then we have smitty smith with the five
dollars
phil dropped the mic and he did it with
flair and he got these ps soldiers
punching the air the book of x now we
have rhymes that's great now we've got
bars oh my god look at that he's been
dropping bars for a minute he's in his
bag he's in his bag
and we have put the crust in the chat
for our newest member outlaw 2120
welcome to the round
thank you thank you um and then hold on
i was not able to keep
keep up with what came afterwards so if
you guys are talking about
me oh my goodness so many man so many
attic jump in there bro
help you help your boy okay i got it i
got it i gotta get it okay cool i got it
we have
stitch with the five dollars absolutely
chicago 49 year old is going to stump on
the 49ers again
listen this football talk right now
shout out to tom
great content lords great to see acg and
rand
woo i mean i'm nowhere near acg's level
so
dude you got your own website you're not
sourced on
i don't even have a website people can
just complain about me and show my face
there we have corey hale with the ten
dollar super chat i would love microsoft
to purchase the black mitt studio that
game looks
insane absolutely
we called blackman the wukong studio yes
yes yes
lord yes yes fine it looks good
we have one we have shawan with the two
super chat do you think xbox can keep
the games flowing post halo
i mean i think that is the point i think
the the point is that game pass is a
beast and you have to keep feeding that
beast
so guaranteed you're going to get more
games um
hold on then we got another new member
to the realm i got jumped once again
yeah we got a couple of them
the man who got them horns oh salute
welcome back
upgraded upgrade oh you upgraded okay
um and i think we're good we're good all
right cool so look we're gonna try to do
some quick
quick hitters you know what i'm saying
real quick and um basically you know we
we saw the announcement right after
actually on that round table
20 bethesda games automatically
included you know i'm saying in game
pass right after the show
you know so just in general like what
are we thinking about the inclusion of
these games and then obviously you know
the future
moving forward with this this
relationship let's get acg and then ran
in as far as you know what you guys
thought was once that announcement
hit i think it's good i was questioning
what games weren't on there because
there were a couple that were
surprising but then i there might be
some technical stuff that's changing
there so it's like i don't know what
exactly is going on but
dude it was awesome i was actually
surprised how many to be honest
i i think i expected maybe like a five
each month
so for them to just be like boom drop
and everything was that was
incredible to me and again that stokes
me up because i'm gonna be the person
playing those old games like
that's it's it's awesome so absolutely
good news i didn't know people played
old games that's news to me
[Laughter]
it's it's great to see um like people
uh they added prey which is such an
underrated title from this gen i see
like code eastwood is loving it like and
i keep on telling like you need to play
this game
so to see all those titles and it's it's
it's
also a lot of work to put all those
titles up there on that service
from my understanding um and yeah there
were some titles missing like
wolfenstein two and evil within two
which i think are both on playstation
now some there may be some
contractual things there where it needs
to run out before they come back right
uh but it's super cool to see the
bethesda
catalog come to game pass for cheap and
then add some of the new features fps
boost
jason ronaldo on your guys show last
week
uh big episode what was it skyrim
special edition
pray yes um fallout 76 fallout 4
and dishonored definitive edition so
it's nice to see those games get 60
frames
but i mean jeez i don't know i don't
know about you guys but
i just gotta say game passes it never
was right brother yeah it's oppressive
impressive value never was
impressive some people's takes will just
not age well when it comes to the stuff
yeah it's interesting to see
lord addict what was your thoughts man
but that's the games
as soon as the the announcement the
round table was done
i was happy man it's it's about time
something like that happened and uh i
think that
as of right now you know this is this is
a good thing
obviously i want to see the games i i
feel like one of the reasons bethesda's
games went downhill a little bit was
just because
they didn't know where they wanted to
meet in the market right you know they
were trying the mmo thing
and i feel like going to xbox they'll be
able to go back to their roots
off what they like to do and not try to
imply some things
to constantly make money so they don't
go out of business i feel that that's a
good point fantastic point
lord saw what did you think 20 bethesda
games
bam right in game pass right after the
answer i just thought it was
great i thought it was great to see that
many and to see
the community engaging with them like
they were brand new games yeah
and the excitement to go play the song
yeah i absolutely ever gonna play this
honor
um as a person who is an unapologetic
immersive sim fan
i am a looking glass like studios fanboy
um to see people excited to see
to play dishonored yeah and to play pray
pray it it warms my heart man it warms
my heart because you look at those games
and those games just didn't do
what i felt they should have done
because the quality is there it's just
that they don't have the name
recognition
of an elder scrolls or a fallout right
so the fact that i'm seeing people
excited to play these games and then
once they start playing them like how
the hell did i
not play this before um it's just it's
that excitement you know
and and i have to give it to the xbox
community because sometimes we'll say
like hey you need to play this you need
to support
these things if you want to see them on
the platform right and to see that
happen
yeah was was very heartening i was i was
super excited to see that yeah man
very cool lord king the lord gained past
himself how did you feel about these
these additions to your service well in
the beginning the game pass it
was uh a hundred games there and you
know they said they would rotate
now you had 300 plus um this is
a phenomenal get yeah majority of those
games i own
i have the physical copies that are
right under the you know the console
that's right there
so um my level of excitement wasn't
really too
high on certain games in those games i
purchased i ended them
but to go back to a lot of those games
for the frame rate boost
yes um and to see how it changed over
you know the period of when i did
purchase it with patches and stuff like
that
you know that was a good thing to do
like i said doom 64.
uh it was amazing um my son
sat there in awe of an old game that he
never got a chance to play
but also he was excited at the list of
games that he was
able to play right uh right off the rip
um
we i don't think that we ever got 20 in
one shot
and these are 20 bangers like yeah
if if you didn't get a chance to play
some of these games like dishonored or
prey and stuff like that and
i feel that game pass has that audience
now
that i tell you it's a buffet yes and
sometimes when you go to go eat your
the thought maybe i wanted to buy some
coconut shrimp but do you want to pay
35.50 for for uh um entree of
coconut shrimp no you don't but you
might want to try a couple of pieces on
your plate
and if you do like it the next time you
go to a restaurant you know yo you know
i did have a coconut shrimp
it did taste like let me get that
coconut shrimp oh let me get that
marinated duck
you know so it's different things that
you're able to try
and taste or at the ice cream aisle
and you're like you know what rice
krispies inside my ice cream
may be really good or the giant chicken
leg
and come down with the knife
let's do it let's do it we're here let's
do it you can't do that if you're paying
on each meal seventy dollars right now
is uh prohibitive
uh for a lot of people at this moment in
time
we're at a different space uh as as uh
as a culture as a group as a as a race
you know so we're trying to save money
any way
we can and we're trying to get the most
out of our buck
this is the most out of your buck yeah
20 games in one shot
if somebody told you right now pay 14.99
and i'm gonna give you 20 games right
now
right you'll do it yeah goodbye
it was great you know great points
everybody said what i wanted to say
values king
it's tremendous you know all these great
titles that people may have missed
on if you're new to the service or you
missed out again you can check this out
and like rand said man for me again we
had jason ronald on
what excites me is just when these
titles are going to get you know fps
boost or any optimization
because now it breathes life back into
the title right now
you're playing this new way and the cool
thing it's optional so if you don't like
the way it's moving or looking
hey you could play it in its original
state as well so you got that you got
the auto hdr all that cool stuff
i'm actually excited to go back to
fallout 4 at 60. you know see how that's
going see how that's rocking
you know from a live service standpoint
i look at something like a fallout 76
and just to see more engagement and more
people in that ecosystem to give it a
shot because it has improved from what i
was told shout out to anchorman he's a
big fan of the game
but um yeah man it's it's exciting and
i'm just exciting to see
you know more getting added you know in
the future and stuff like that and it
was tremendous to see it
instantly boom shot in the arm but
there's the titles
you know what i'm saying so that's what
i got on it so i want to move on
to the final topic there which is uh
sony's response and what you know should
they do anything you know actually
solve this is your top so let me let you
frame it you know you're the one that
brought it up in the room like what what
was your thought process
after this announcement you know in
regards to sony oh yeah obviously after
after everything became uh sort of
crystal clear
that that that uh platforms without game
pass would not be receiving these games
in the future
obviously sections of the internet had
opinions about what sony should do
in response to this if anything so
obviously there was a section that said
hey they don't need to do anything just
keep doing what they're doing
uh their studios are fantastic they're
gonna have these these sort of
you know amazing sort of triple a
experiences that
only sort of they have shown that they
they
they that's what they do that's what
they wanted um
other people have said no they need to
respond in some way shape or form they
need to i've heard
everything from buy take two interactive
to buy konami and buy buy square enix
people got no chill man they go straight
for the talk
straight for the juggler with this sort
of stuff so um what i want to know from
you guys is
any of this stuff realistic what do you
think do they have to respond in some
way shape or form i think it's obvious
that like acg said like you know
obviously they have
mac they're machinating things right not
necessarily as a response to this but
everybody's always looking
um so something's bound to happen
but is it something on the level of of
what microsoft did um can they even do
that
and do they even need to do that when
you look at you know what they've done
recently with ps plus
where when you look at ps now and sort
of where that is and it feels like ps
plus
is sort of their way of responding if
obviously it's different than game pass
but is there sort of way of responding
to that
what do you guys think is in the cards
for sony in in in response to quote
unquote to what microsoft has done with
bethesda
let me go first because i have to leave
here okay
like i don't necessarily think that they
have to respond
but i do think that there's going to be
a time when these studios
that microsoft has purchased along with
bethesda start popping out
consistent content right and i think
that
sooner or later sony's not
is going to get outpaced in context sure
they're going to make the
god of war no one's ever going to take
them away from that but to me
you know when you took look at it from
like a perspective of value
look at that perspective on just general
content and and
and all you know once the pandemic and
stuff you know starts
forming off and the uh these games start
getting developed out and get
started get pushed out the door you know
it's like we were saying this year
star field you know what happens in two
years to three years when
they got three or four studios hitting
every cylinder every year
and and sony got one to two to three
right so
you're talking from a volume perspective
i'm talking from a volume down okay you
know
obviously we don't know what some of
these studios are making for microsoft
but
if they're decent on quality and a lot
of them have high quality
i do feel like sooner or later people's
gonna start look like look
god of war amazing i'm gonna buy
playstation for that
but over here is game pass and they're
dropping three
good good games a year right in like two
to three
okay to average games a year right and i
think the content is eventually going to
outweigh what playstation's doing
and especially like you know we talk
about up until now
when people brought up microsoft buying
sega microsoft buying
whatever other you know rumors they have
it was always that standpoint a lot of
people had well
bethesda's games are going to be
multiplied so it doesn't matter if they
buy sega
but now we know that they have no
problem locking some of this content
behind
so what happens if they buy sega and
then sony
loses with a persona franchise you know
the good thing that sony has going for
them now
is they have such good relationships
with people they could just double down
on double o
on on second party studios you know
with the final fantasies the personas
and that's
definitely going to help even it out but
if microsoft buys like something like
sega which i'm not saying they're going
to i'm just saying there is
you know some things out there that make
that seem a little bit plausible
then i do feel like sooner or later
sony's going to have to answer that
and it's not even a perspective of
volume it's the perspective of
if we don't buy that studio microsoft
might buy it
so like protecting your assets or so to
speak
no i hear you may get making some some
interesting points you know a lot of
people
do feel that way let's get our lord acg
in man sony's response
if any do they need to do something
where yet
no i mean they'll they'll continue to do
what they do and the market
will adjust and they'll see like in the
future they what i'm saying is they
don't need to go out and buy somebody
tomorrow
that's ridiculous that's what a console
fanboy is who's
yeah exactly that's like somebody on a
playground you know thinks that's
you know you punch me i punch you dude
i poison you three days later you don't
even know
right that's so i think sony uh has
great games
they'll do their stuff they'll look at
things they'll decide things they'll
have other companies come in and
offer them uh sony's does a great job at
cultivating
really good games yes uh unlike let's
say days gone which i would
even if you love days gone i would say
days gone is almost sony's first big
miss or a miss at least a bump in the
road for that they're
the the way they try to deliver their
titles for that third-person action game
so um i think sony's and nintendo are
fine people forget nintendo
but uh not really i can't i think
they'll just continue
and adjust their business slightly they
were already trying to buy exclusivity
so it's not like you can buy buy
exclusivity they were already doing that
prior to this purchase
yes if that makes sense so those deals
they were already doing that and i think
they might step it up a little bit
but man they got some good games you
know also people are forgetting
microsoft has a couple big gifts that
haven't been announced yet um that will
be on game pass that are not first
party which that's the one thing that i
will say
i don't know how other company fights
that so what i mean by that is
sony has done it in the past as well
microsoft bought the rights for the
two gta 4 expansions as well remember
they paid for those to be developed
so this has happened before game pass
and getting a big third party exclusive
even on game pass
that that's one place where i do think
sony has to figure something out and i'm
not 100 sure what they will do right
we've seen yeah we've seen the rumors
with this anomaly game right supposedly
being a new game that
you know the signal right and everyone's
pointing to like the story of outriders
and
a potential pen that's something we
haven't seen i want to say
the achilles heel of game pass but we we
haven't seen that
triple a new game as opposed to like
four months down the road or whatever
kind of debut it's usually been their
first party exactly
so that's something that is interesting
if they adopt that acg
you know how does sony compete with that
so to speak exactly yeah yeah
i don't know that's yeah the good thing
going on right now is like
outriders if it is just you know i i
don't know
but but you know let's say outriders
does come out one of the things that's
really going to help them in game pass
is its cross play
yes so it's going to give a lot of multi
console owners should i buy it on
playstation or play it on console
and then not to mention the word of
mouth is going to go on it's like it's
all
you know that this game is awesome and
then you know you got the xbox people in
the cross play logs i didn't pay for it
lord rand sony response do they need to
do something do you need to get it
get back up no i mean i agree with acg
it's it's it's one of those like sony's
going to do with what they've
continued to do which is grow
organically right right you're at this
point now
where sony has these stable of studios
but they're
in the process of making them multi-team
so you have guerrilla games that's true
yeah they're doing horizon
and then a rumored shooter which may or
may not be
socom right they're doing the same thing
with sony santa monica they got god of
war coming and then
rumored sci-fi corey balrog game right
so their strategy is okay we don't
necessarily need to buy more studios
we're just going to increase the
production level of the current studios
we
we own by hiring more people and
that's what i think sony's going to
focus on right um they might buy some
yeah they might buy some like other like
blue point games
you know rumors surrounding them right
maybe house smartphone depending on how
returnable actually
but like publishers i know i know people
won't be like
what would happen if they buy capcom or
konami it's like
i mean capcom doesn't want to be bought
out at this point uh
but like it is it is a fanboy thing to
be like well
you got bethesda so we'll go get this
now i don't think they're ever going to
go out and buy a publisher like
well you know never say never because
they almost they were all they did they
were in the running for leo you or lay
you
or the the parent company who owns
digital extremes and warframe they just
got beat up by 10 cent
so they were looking at that they were
in the running i will say though if
microsoft continues
the aggressive approach which we think
they will right and if they buy another
large publisher
say say go warner brothers you know wb
games or something
right then i could see jim ryan being
like
oh okay
wow i'm drowning do the drowning signal
he just he just does the thumbs up the
thumbs up that's awesome
they're going to keep on the path and
they're just going to invest and grow
their
you know great studios they already have
no cool question ryan
let's say that the something does happen
and microsoft does buy another publisher
like sega they will buy
okay okay that is fine that has nothing
to do with the question i'm gonna
ask the question you don't have to to to
buff your chest out they will
answer the damn question all i was
asking you
is like that is the point where i do
feel like sony would have to start
you know not necessarily by publishers
but it's like yo if they buy sega if
they buy warner brothers like
like sooner or later if they're like if
they're first parties like almost
quadruple the amount that sony has
i do feel like that sooner or late gonna
be an issue like
well there's i mean there's only so many
publishers out there some of them are
extremely expensive
one person has the money yeah i i do
agree with you though when it comes to
how they're going to fix
the content they're just going to double
their studios because
who's the best people to make the the
games like sure you could go out there
and get the blue points and get the
and get the you know score but the best
people to make the games is the people
that's been putting you on the map
already right so it's better to double
those studios to have them work on two
spaces
and and the reason i say microsoft will
buy a publisher is because
oh he's backing up now is i'm not
backing up i'm saying the reason they're
going to do it is because
um i mean satya nadella and phil both
said they're they're looking
right and they are almost at the limit
of what matt booty can
essentially run with 15 studios of xbox
game studios
teams right right like he's at his his
limit okay so what do you do you just
slide in a publisher that can run itself
like all you got to do is just integrate
it you slide them in that's
like how bethesda's doing you can do
that with another publisher
and they run itself you know so um
[Music]
although i love king's enthusiasm right
i love
his overzealousness with this
you know i mean king said it's overrated
king says it's over and you know the
time
i know you say it all the time i've been
right you've been wrong
act like you ain't been wrong son you've
been more right than wrong
i don't think i don't think i don't
think there's a uh sony has a major
issue yet um if game pass can disrupt
the market and become
uh that uh paradigm shift eventually
there might be a a problem but that's
for
for that's for five to ten years down
the road no i think oh look
ahead because clearly you disagree with
this a whole lot faster and he knows it
too
this is the thing like i love your
humbleness i swear to god i love that i
love your humbleness and i love exactly
what you mapped out and what you did map
out you mapped out everything correctly
what you said was everything was correct
ma booty has
15 studios that he is overseeing
right fantastic we have that microsoft
understood
we need development houses because at
one point in time sony was outnumbering
them
with their prime development great but
now that is not the case
matt booty is controlling that situation
when they purchase bethesda the purchase
was desert because they purchased
a developer a producer and a distributor
so when they can run their own
shop but be under your banner right
so in doing so you know that okay all
they need is to have a little bit of
oversight here
we can check this stuff out here they've
done quality work we've worked with
these guys
right we will integrate with them and
see other things how we can help each
other
right that is a fully functional
warehouse
i feel all right this is not you going
into a warehouse purchasing
an empty place you're purchasing a
business that is fully functional
that has tensions all over the place and
you're putting your name on it
now this is what microsoft is doing now
they're not going out buying exclusive
deal let me get a uh
excuse me can i get a game for a week
for time they're not going and
rearranging the shelf
uh inside the store and trying to tell
you it's a different product
no they're not doing that what they're
doing is purchasing
distribution arm sony's a mom and pop
shop hold on
real they got mom and pop money right oh
my god
across the street walmart is across the
street what is the mom and pop shop
gonna do they go outside and they put
banners up and they're saying
we got stuff on the low low
and how about that and they're selling
you the same exact things that they've
been selling you
right i'm saying god of war right okay
all right so god of war came out the
horizon came out
and it did this it's going to sell to
one percent of their democrats
all right so one percent of your
demographic gets to see your game
and you're still in the same rut that
you are
they're one miss away from being gone oh
my god
okay no we said that before with them
so this is guy or straight oh oh we are
we applying if they don't have another
successful ip they're entire strengths
i'm losing everybody's point yes right
okay so now we got that distribution we
got this whole big machine
moving over here now what happened
before we always said what happens if
microsoft actually backs xbox
oh they're backing them now
they're actually making a vested
investment in them
we was all worried about google until
the bethesda deal
all right so now that one one pawn is
off the board
those are the white walkers right
zerkaris
oh my god the game of thrones references
gone right those white walkers are gone
right you know the white walkers killed
them for dragons yeah they did
they did what happened though they're
gone
they slipped the knife inside you saw
that yes get up
out of here okay now you got these one
dudes
they're still there if
if they don't make the pivot this is
sony's move this is sony move jim
pull your air closed jim ryan please get
that play store give you some great
advice
get that playstation now right do
exactly what microsoft is doing
you guys are the co you're the copycat
kings oh lord you are the copy
you're the accident champions that
shouldn't be here you are the copycat
kings
so what you need to do is every game
first party game
put it in playstation now date and date
you're not going to lose any money trust
me jim you're going to make a ton of
money you're going to get a ton
of bread a ton of bread and make sure
that you get that playstation now inside
the epic store
make sure the epic store has it make
sure that your playstation games is on
pc
and also on the playstation platform
day and date make sure that happens why
i will subscribe
and your subscriptions
i i don't give you any money so you you
want me
to be into your ecosystem check this out
once you do that once you start growing
that debt that that
level of subscription service people
starting to see the value in the
playstations now
because there's no reason why
playstation now is out first and you're
still at 2 million subscribers come on
man come on man
other than it sucks
no i'm sorry yeah sony completely
separate
but they're online everything is a
disaster like
they need to fix remember that uh what's
his name jack trenton
had to state that sony did not want to
him to apologize
about the hacking and at the he talked
about this on uh on
uh ign with ryan mccabe where he stated
he had he went out and decided against
them
stating i'm gonna apologize to people
they are
backwards just like nintendo online
nintendo nintendo thinks online is two
styrofoam cups with some
i wish i wish it is yeah dude
they don't even know what online means
yeah where's the messages
and sony's the same way yeah admittedly
sony and microsoft did
discuss as azure so that that is
absolutely true
with some little chips and some little
trinkets from them
it's almost like you want a competitor
in the nfl so you give them a couple
players
keep them there but i will say that
hiring bethesda is like hiring a
quarterback that can call their own
plays yes which is a little and i think
that
king was absolutely right that is that
is a
different we've never seen that before
so that'll be very interesting to see
how these two
who are pretty close i would say in the
pecking order
how they're going to handle absolutely
you know
jim you're going to do it because jim is
a
jim's the number guy remember jim is
going to get these numbers up
jim is going to shift this money around
now for the playstation hearts
i don't want my games no place else i
want to pay
75 out nobody listening to you
are you applying to the vocal minority
you are absolutely out of your mind
i want a playstation now service with
date and date it's pretty tone-deaf
about the price
no no no if i had kids i wouldn't be
like here's this
i scrounged together like three bucks
and i was happy for a week
70 game for a kid maybe once every three
or four four
months maybe christmas yeah yeah see
christmas
birthday you get these milestone dates
that you get games
yeah exactly is that your birthday right
yeah
let every day be your birthday my son
thought yesterday was his birthday oh my
god it wasn't
it was just the desert your son is gonna
have to he's gonna have a messed up idea
of how old he is
like in a year he'll be like i'm 75 man
because multiple games have come out
i've just had multiple
multiple birthdays in one year
gonna have a beard like us just suddenly
you're like what the hell
[Music]
but you know this that's that's the
pivot that they have you know
they're gonna they're gonna hunker there
i i don't want them to do what y'all
said
i don't want them to to not react
now i don't want them i don't want them
to go away
you know i really no i don't want them
to go away this is yourself
um phil is gonna do what he said he
going to do
which is and just like he said
those games that you want so bad because
you guys want them because you're crying
about them
and if you want them your bosses want
them
and in order to get that just got to put
this oh
wait this is about gay pass let's get
that
not to bend the knee but i want to i
want to get king on this
um do you think during this generation
no we get game pass yeah that's the
question no
not this generation no okay okay so you
think they would refuse that
i think when they die that happened
when you know you know you know when the
generation is one
and playstation started like the like
when the playstation 3 when the
generation was over
and playstation 3 was like yeah last of
us
the funny thing is that we have these
conversations about what these platforms
are
do and are accustomed to doing right
right but if you look at the
conversations that happened
already right if you look at the impact
of fortnite and how it forced cross play
and now yeah cross play is this
ubiquitous thing now that you can't rock
it out
right rocket league and rocket league as
well um and then you look at
that mlb deal right the mlb deal i
guarantee you this
if that contract had expired at the
start of the ps4 generation
and mlb comes to playstation and says
hey we love your game we want you to
keep making it
but we want you to put it everywhere i
can almost guarantee you
that the answer to that is thank you
very much we're done making baseball
games
as opposed to at the end of the
generation where you had
new management in charge the the
the ideologies changed somewhat and now
you have different thinking
so i don't honestly man i i honestly
don't know what will happen
right but i i do feel that if xbox makes
these power plays right and again we
haven't seen these games yet right
the quality of the game sucks all the
movements that they've made mean nothing
exactly
but if they hit with banger after banger
and they keep getting
more um more products for game pass
i do think the conversation about a
pivot
on the playstation side happens sooner
rather than later
um it's just it's weird because again i
would have never in a million years
thought that they would
acquiesce to cross-play you remember uh
you know playstation we
all care about the children
don't don't forget that um playstation
allowed xbox live
on psn for my minecraft something that
you would think would have never
happened
never never same thing on nintendo i do
have a question though for you guys
you know where phil's comments about
where game pass exists is is pretty much
like
he's not shutting the door right on
nintendo or playstation eventually in
the future so let me ask you guys this
what is more likely game pass xcloud
coming to
ps5 in the future or game pass xcloud
coming to switch in the future
i already know it's coming in man
i don't think there's a competition
between switch
microsoft have a weird difference i
agree so i think that they could
they sony has an ego thing with
microsoft too
there's something there where nintendo i
think they might just be like
okay that would be a huge absolutely
huge announcement
i think he's complicit i think jim ryan
is in pocket
listen listen okay this is like straight
up illuminati
thank you acg thank you thank you check
this out
remember that picture where phil was
standing on stage and he had sean layton
on one side of reggie on the other
yeah i told these dudes that same day i
said
that means a lot it does stand in the
middle
he stood there he looked to the left and
he looked to the right
the first one was gone and the next one
is going through oh my god
people that are complicit in their spots
you know bowser is complicit you know um
dance movement
is complicit these guys are complicit to
the program
program is to make sure that game pass
is gonna be on your box
nintendo a little bit later the
hierarchy over there is like we don't
know
we don't know we don't know but once jim
dance moves ryan just starts to show
the gap in between and we can have this
type of revenue if we can just do this
one thing
it'll happen but do i think it happens
in this generation
they will have to get beat down
immensely
terrible will have to happen blood in
the snow all the time
but yo yo
sony first nintendo seconds oh my god
look let me jump here
this is hilarious oh to grant's question
um you know i do agree i think switch
would be more likely
i will never say never with sony but
again i just don't see it right now but
um
look to saab's overall point you know as
far as like what's going on doing all
that stuff i mean look just
i'm in agreement with rand just keep
doing what you've been doing make great
games
you know what i'm saying they're still
going to be competitive in the gen
provided games you know come out with
the same cadence they have
and they're great you know i am curious
uh lord acg
if one strategy we heard that they were
adopting at the beginning of jen
was the timed exclusive route you know
they heard they were going to third
parties and try and obviously we heard
with starfields things of that nature
you know so i i want to see if they
continue that you know as even with the
dlc practices and stuff like that
as well as um exclusive games um
to addict's point you know in reference
to volume there is
i do obviously acg you made a good point
about
covid really affecting development from
studios right
so you know provided that situation gets
better and as we move on
i am concerned with showing how they
would deal with the cadence
of once all 23 studios start rolling
right you know and then they get into
this thing when maybe per
quarter you could have one or two you
know solid xbox titles or whatever
you know that stuff starts to add up
again we know these guys sony are
artists they make these amazing
experiences no one's gonna take away the
quality but i do i am concerned of a
of a sheer volume quality versus
waiting for these amazing things that
may be spaced out a bit longer right
so i'm curious to see how that plays out
and um look i just think at the end
it's gonna be a great gen this is gonna
be
a good job and what i've always preached
at the beginning
of this gym people like people would
tell me oh there's no way microsoft
complete look at what happened to xbox
one this teddy third
all of us most of us here on this panel
are old enough to see
regimes and empires fall change we've
seen it we've seen the sega's
we've seen you know if you would have
told me and ran i've told you this had
nauseum right
like if you'd have told me during the
nintendo wii
generation the switch would be the
nintendo's next console will be the most
dominant
but i would have laughed you out of the
room right
so at the end of the day it's a clean
slate
at the start of a generation it and like
for rand's point you know with the whole
hominic 5 million 6 million maybe
current right now
you know on our playstation and
microsoft adopting this
a strategy of exclusives right say like
we don't necessarily need to put
that those games over there this is
going to be a fun ride man it's going to
be competitive
both have all three have these unique
strategies right yeah
yeah it's like nintendo's got this niche
thing the handheld the hybrid
sony the exclusive the bangers you know
what i'm saying now microsoft with the
studios the publisher
it's going to be fun y'all just buckle
up it's going to be a competitive gen
that's what i got if anyone else wants
to jump in before you did um playstation
drop any games yet
oh my god you know
upstairs to play some games
we got everybody got anything else
before we get the super chat get up out
of here for the six hour podcast we've
been doing it
we have chief mint with the five dollar
super chat i came for jason ronald and
stayed for randall thor
new fan here keep it up i don't know if
they meant they came last week
yes as for jason ronald or if they think
acg is jason ronald
[Laughter]
the creator of the series
xbox signals uh signaling a move towards
game passes this
make promoting the console anomaly
this mystery to me i'm out and writing
no matter what
i'm out and writing no matter what yeah
everybody's out writer's joke
yeah that's what it is i would feel that
if it wasn't outrider square enix would
have been putting out that fire
immediately yes right like because that
would affect your your day one sale
so if it was if it wasn't they'd be like
no outriders isn't coming to game pass
yeah so they haven't said anything yet
so what if they brought them oh
my god and i tell you this this speaks
to that whole idea of
finally getting that big third party day
and dates
on that service um yeah i love first
party games
and they they're great for establishing
identity
but a third-party banger across all of
those platinum yeah
bro and acg man you've talked you know
in reference to
you know live service games and like we
see what's happening with avengers right
now right
but 500 in there like so 500 people
playing that
wow wow on the pc i'm talking about the
pc that it should have been all the way
past exactly that should have been on
game no that's what we talked about so
we talked about it
i look at a situation i know i'm a
hardcore destiny fan but i tell people
all the time i look at the situation
destiny 2 beyond light new expansion bam
right in gamepad and
bungie's all about engagement in numbers
and seeing that player base and i'm
telling you i i see it when i look at
most games played and you look at that
list on
like i remember when destiny was in like
the 20s it wasn't now it's consistently
in the top five top eight
it's insane it's insane what that does
to a game like that so outright is
would fit the bill continue yeah for
free
yeah i just want to make mention that
you know this outriders thing is
it's like square enix apologizing to
xbox and being like hey sorry you're not
getting final finances seven remake
yeah um but here have outriders day one
and game pass there you go
yeah it kind of feels that way because
they they said nothing about final
fighting seven remakes
you know another game that people have
said nothing about capcom
uh and resident evil 7 vr for pc
there's very particular exclusives that
you can tell are being re-bought
for their exclusivity whenever because
usually it's a year contract
yeah but you can definitely tell summer
just like keep paying for each year
absolutely
what else we got solved then we got
pillsbury 27 with the ten dollars
acg is the goat of gaming reviews
but the podcast is off the chain
randolph door 19 is best for xbox news
sony should not be complacent remember
the ps3 and sony caught up with the xbox
360.
yeah they caught up when we stopped
trying oh my god
what type of race is that i already went
home you got to the finish line
admittedly that is that's a legitimate
we've
looked at numbers on that that's
actually a somewhat legitimate
discussion
really we should do that yeah we should
do it there's a legitimate discussion
on timing and who left timing timing and
to the power of the playstation name
regardless of
oh true that yeah the last of us did
that
for sure good game they finished strong
they finished strong always
yeah we got a load of roughness five
dollar super chat
roughness people say sooner or later
with sony they need to do things sooner
because another bit does the level
purchase there'll be there'll be no
later for some
oh my god fatalists over here
savage then we have our brother
fonzarelli
king is one of the funniest dudes in the
community much love to the ilp
and your continued success thank you did
anybody watch fonz's last video
oh my god it was hilarious yo subscribe
he's a channel fonzarelli gaming that is
the homie
love his takes wanna get away yeah salt
west airline
road trip he is a beast man he doesn't
do more videos i love a fuzzy belly
video yeah i'm glad that fonz is back i
know he took some time good to see him
brother
what's up we have some king etc with the
two pound super chat
console war is dead subscription war has
started
yeah that makes sense so it could be
support then we have
flame with the two dollars which had
this is the podcast
i was waiting for all now mm-hmm nice
salute salute flying we can hear you
addict what's up you good
okay and it's back in the bushes i don't
know what's going on
anyway moving on we all caught up now
yeah all right cool man let's get this
poll
and get out let's get out of here she's
got one more super chat that just came
out
yeah x x bot be the
best box and game fast will be the thing
that outlasts
and the next bethesda level purchase may
just be square enix when what
uh then what please discuss uh we can't
really discuss
that's what i said but amen amen
stay tuned stay tuned mr orange
mr orange with the five dollar super
chat i got five on everything
salute all right last j let's get up out
of here that new lawsuit gaming.net po
up right now so check it out all
regarding phil spencer clarifying
bethesda games exclusive to platforms
where xbox game pass
exists which games do you feel are
multi-platform contractual obligations
or exceptions to this rule the choices
are eight
starfield b new indiana jones game
or c i don't care about bethesda gays
don't work cause they not on my platform
of choice
shout out to all the lords of the romans
up right now
lords of gaming.net make your vote heard
we really appreciate the feedback we
like to do these fun polls
but again we gotta salute the legendary
lord
acg for rocking with us trump
tremendous gaming history brother tell
the people where they could find you
what you got going on man
uh i don't even know my url that's how
well i sell myself
i don't even think it as angry centaur
gaming but anyway acg
on youtube you can look it up i do video
game reviews we do podcasts on itunes
and spotify
and uh and i will definitely be on again
oh it's hilarious
we we do ours so i'm gonna have to get
you guys on ours too
i wanna do like an eight person because
we have four they're around the world
australia there's austria finland and
get everybody in here and just
go off it would be an hour
seven hour podcast yo the lords love
that
yeah just bring your porta potty with
you
you'll see the blank look on my face and
i'll just be like
one second but yeah thanks for having me
man
absolute pleasure this is amazing i love
what you do
love what you represent and again just
the integrity
and reviewing the style the humor having
fun with it man brother we like i said
you thought the bad signal will be there
and you know you will be back in the
round man salute this is a hilarious if
fun
love the end of course pulling up doing
his victory lap of predictions
as he always does the man broke the pc
uh the playstation stuff to pc earlier
and then um
you know now it's going it was an iop
exclusive i was an iop exclusive he he
got
stoned in the streets remember the
people stoned him
they were like this is no way possible
randolph
zero dawn's never covered the people he
knows the value of exclusives
you got killed and then rand has been uh
he's been telling me to hold the line
[ __ ] without but i was frustrated with
marketing speak and you were like nope
it's gonna be exclusive
salute to the man with the million my
friend and new destiny clan member i
might say
lord randolph of it where can the people
find you what you got going on sir hey
thanks for having me on again cog
uh king lord sovereign lord addict mr
acg
so uh first time meeting you uh love
your content
thanks yeah it's been a blast and uh
yeah i mean you can check me out youtube
you know youtube.comrandothorn19
we're mostly cover xbox related stuff
and i'll probably have another video out
tonight
uh talking about some some little small
xbox little news thing so
appreciate you guys having me on
appreciate you brother always i guess
appreciate the support i appreciate your
balance
perspective i always feel you know as a
primary xbox or
podcast and and platform you always
say sometimes even the difficult things
that even some fanboys don't want to
hear
and you you definitely do your thing
brother so again appreciate shout out
for the shout out that you gave on the
video i want to also thank you for that
and when we had jason on that was a big
moment for us and you showed a lot of
love
and again most bigger entities sometimes
don't always
show love to small ants so i respect you
you know what i'm saying
that and again just love gaming with you
the homie lord ran out thought man
celebrate you always been supportive for
day one i gotta shout you out for that
lord addict are you still there sir are
you at work i'm here sorry i was doing
the um
that tournament thing at the same time
uh first off i want to
definitely thank you for coming on acg
it's yeah
it's it's a nice thing to go from
watching someone
so regularly for years to having them on
and actually having a conversation with
them if that makes sense yes
yeah yeah uh always been a huge fan uh
you know
shout out to the iop community plus
people that's the first time we've ever
and shout out to everybody saying yo
i've never heard of acg i'm subscribed
to this
like suits a lot of people there that's
cool yeah it's awesome but also shout
out to everybody who does know all of us
that's
really the best part i love it when
people are like
the overlap there's something cool about
when somebody's like oh my god i didn't
know you guys were coming off yeah it
was like a mashed wash up like
like yo they coming together oh this is
great yeah yeah it was dope it's like we
did a little collabo album i i respect
it
continue lord son what's going
on sir look at the five people find your
scooter yeah man first off i mean
randy you know you family man we're
happy to provide the platform for you to
do victory lapses
it's always welcome here to do victory
laps
i tell you man um i'm that dude who
usually
i'm not you know in the in these twitter
and youtube streets like these guys are
so i oftentimes come to people's um
content
when they come on the podcast with you
is a little bit different because
the first time i got to experience you
was on defining duke and i was like this
guy's awesome
oh hold up and then i gravitated to all
the rest of your stuff
but i tell you um the fact how you
approach reviews
how it's no-nonsense and you take the
time to break down things in your
reviews in ways that
other uh people don't do um it's
absolutely amazing and just
thank you it's one of those things like
after podcasting with you for four hours
now
like besides being a fan like you're
you're a kindred spirit of ours yeah
we've gone through a lot of stuff we've
gone through it's always fun to have
somebody
on this from the era that we come to
understand
it's fantastic having you on all the
best to you fantastic success i love the
fact that you're on colin's platform
because i know that is that that's a
platform where it's like
you can be you you can be you yeah no
questions asked
and that's fantastic so much continued
success to you no doubt
thank you lord king the the fans like i
said
they were chastising me cog don't
interrupt him i don't unleash king i
don't want to hit any of this
playstation
balance perspective garbage cac
jack exactly they're like he's gotta
talk
king's gotta talk this is his moment
it's his moment exactly
okay i wanna address ran first real
quick no doubt right
i'm happy that you're playing destiny
can you guys hear me yes yeah okay i
just want to point out real quick king
that uh
you know iop is participating in halo
tournament so you can go on my channel
oh yeah right now go to the game right
here we got attic in five rings
um cog told me later i'll talk about
that later
um but i i want to thank you know ran uh
for all the stuff that he does because
you know we talk at night when i get a
chance like when we get a chance you
know
we we took for granted that uh we were
uh on each other's friends list when we
wasn't really weird
um and so we are now and he's in the
clan so i can't wait to run
you know super night falls with him is
up next yeah and show him some stuff
um that's going to be amazing now
i gotta say that he is probably one of
the most humblest
yes people that i know yes
because he is a regular humble guy
and he sits on a ton of information and
he goes at it with an even hand
yes very even yes where i i tip my hand
all the way to the left
he's in the middle and he's very even
and i
really respect all his videos i got to
say this though
i don't know what you did to my
television but every time i go to sleep
you know i
put it on youtube and i'll let youtube
run i wake up to you
and just shout out to the algorithm
every single time that's literally
i'm a fraud oh i'm an elephant
alert clip this clipping fraud
for not knowing who acg was
oh for not knowing you've gained nothing
no but actually meeting you and
interacting with you today
i've gained a lot i'm going to subscribe
i'm going to watch because these dudes
are telling stories and i'm sitting
there with fomo
like the ultimate fomo and i wasn't
gonna go through my phone while we were
watching right
to catch up on stuff um but
i love your take on things i love how
you analyze stuff
and i love the pillars in your life you
mentioned your wife
you mentioned kung fu
[Music]
the disciplines um and you mentioned
video games and then
you mentioned other aspects of your life
uh how you approach
uh doing reviews and and different
things
and i was entrenched and in in endeared
to all the stuff that you went through
and all the stuff that you're going
through
and the fantastic stuff that you're
doing so
i can't wait to be a part of your world
to see more into your world because you
are a fantastic
interesting dude and i understand now
why everybody was like acg
crazy man i appreciate it we're getting
now we're just going to have to get
everybody together
we're going to have to do it we do it we
got it i definitely appreciate it
absolutely man yeah king killing it so
you guys can catch me
on uh dolph castle x fridays at 9 00 pm
best damn statue podcast uh statues are
inside the red room and uh these recipe
statues are going to go these are
modular you get rid of the voltron fan
no no no no he's going inside the uh the
purple room oh god
with the other transformers um hawk is
going inside the red room um
so these right here these are magic
cases they're going to go on top and
they're going to be
different cells inside and they light up
and all that stuff so the display is
going to change so i'm doing everything
by myself i was doing it sick uh cogno i
went to the hospital this morning
yes he did that soon as i finished work
stretch ran straight to the hospital
uh check myself out making sure
everything's okay and i know you're like
well you look good for going to the
hospital
absolutely so yeah went make sure
everything is good and
um i just want you guys to know i
appreciate
every last one of you yeah watching and
rocking with us
all this time listening to my tom
foolery
yes um you know putting up with it
listen i say a lot of the stuff
tongue-in-cheek but a lot of the stuff i
said
say because i believe i truly believe
certain things
and i know it may be hurtful for some of
you guys but just go buy a lockhart
just go buy a series that's and join us
join us
[Music]
uh yeah we got slow-mo backslap with the
five dollar super attack just getting
here
gonna have to watch the replay salute
lords and remember friends don't let
friends play
destiny my man slowly let's see we ain't
gonna do that slander slow you know i
like you stop it
then we got fit cloud gaming with the 20
super chat
last one for today congrats on 200
episodes my dude salute
i love you guys likewise my brother all
the best of health to you and your
mother um we're rooting for you
absolutely
he skipped over the newest member of the
iron lords podcast uh clan member
yes the one who left his clan to join
yes
gaming forte with the two dollar super
chat shout out to the four hour podcast
love you guys you know what it is with
the lord's best salute man we all caught
we got everything right
yeah yeah man look man tremendous again
much appreciated lord acg
lord ram pulling up fantastic show again
episode 200 we couldn't do this without
you guys again the support has
been phenomenal looking forward to more
fun things in the room
can't wait to share more exciting stuff
exclusives
and again addict salute to him for uh
blessing the realm and giving back as
well
that's all i got everybody look enjoy
your sunday
everybody out of here
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
so
you